hey what's going on it's Bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
you know as much as I'm checking in on
you I wish that you would like maybe
check in on me
sometimes oh Billy freckles if you knew
Billy like I knew Billy oh oh oh what a
cold this [__] lingering ass
cold has been in my house for weeks and
I I haven't got it and I've been
interacting with my kids being a good
father and I just kept taking vitamins
and eating raw ginger and [__] all
natural
honey that really isn't all natural they
just removed one ingredient and it's the
same [__] from the [__] grocery store
and now they can put it into Trader
Joe's and have't called call it
natural
um Trader
Joe's it should they should call that
place you [__] Traitor
Joe [__] Traitor
Joe um did you hear about that most of
the [__] they're saying that's in
Traders Joe's is in the other
Supermarket that was [__] poisoning
you and all they have to do is they that
they the food Lobby is so [__] strong
all they like all right all right all
right we'll take one thing
out and now we can call it organic cuz
we decide and you're just eating the
same [__] minus one
ingredient
um
allegedly
allegedly oh I'm sweating here roasting
bacon boiling it's like a
Sona um holy
[__] the [__] Buffalo
Bills I was watching that game going
like they can't do this to their fans
again like they they just they
cannot [__] do this um shout out to
that that dude
sass uh they're going to blame
you they're going to [__] blame you
but it's [__] the [__] Buffalo
Bills I mean they did like it's like
they wanted to lose that game how many
dropped passes how many times did you
hear Tony Romo go you know he he should
have caught that now granted he sides
with the quarterback but there was times
right
through W like [__] open and and
Allan puts the ball where it needs to be
right doesn't happen chiefs made plays
the bills didn't and I and you know that
[__] fake
punt on your own 30 yard
line that was a debacle that should have
iced a game for the Chiefs but your
defense bailed you out you had like
[__] six key drop
passes and even if you made that feeli
goal all that would have done was tie it
up you know the chiefs were going to go
down they were going to go down they
were going to cut your hearts out one
way or the other so you got it over with
but you know the whole wide right thing
just fits the narrative oh the two
saddest
words you know in
Buffalo it's not wide right the two
saddest words are lake effect
[Laughter]
effect
ah two saddest words in Buffalo near
Rochester there's way more sadder words
than [__] wide right
um
anyway the Buffalo Bills are not ready
for prime time okay that's just
basically it they're good enough to get
there they're not good enough to win and
you know if you want to take the
frustration I'll out on the field goal
kicker and really not take a look at
your life and the relationships that
you're having and how you feel every
time he or she or they open their
[__]
mouth and you're going to ignore that
voice in your head that's saying how in
the
[__] out of all the human beings I could
have cohabitated with that I ended up
with this person you
know and the voice in your head just
starts growing stronger every day like
The Telltale Heart right and it finally
just you know just say it just say it
I'm not
happy this isn't working for me I want
out I want out
right I'm doing it this weekend I'm
doing it and then what
happens there's a playoff game in your
city there's a party people drink
they're watching it it's a disappointing
loss and now you're going to go home and
Trauma
bond with that person that you don't you
just don't love him
anymore okay people this is why you need
to have a good game plan on Sundays or
Mondays because it affects
people so much more Beyond just the
game how about that [__] [__] in the
crowd just breaking down crying I mean
that was [__]
ridiculous I'm sorry like I would be if
that was my son I would be like what in
the [__] was that were you watching a
romantic
comedy you know did remember those
[__] awful romantic
comedies and these [__] writers would
always have to come up with that
line to make all the women be like oh oh
you
know you complete
me first of all that is an awkward
clunky [__]
line you complete me you make me want to
be a better
man you could just say [__] like that in
the 90s and [__] women would lose
their mind like watching the
movie that line doesn't work in real
life you make me want to be a better man
she' just be looking at you like well
okay are you going to be a better man
you haven't really committed to anything
with that [__]
statement why did you give me that big
stupid dramatic look before you said
it this is all a bunch of talk Jack I
need
action
um like that [__] dude
crying crying like he's the first sports
fan ever to experience a devastating
loss go [__] yourself and everybody has
anybody suffered
more than the [__] Buffalo Bill
fans what the [__] are you talking
about
suffering they're like mid middle age
sufferers I don't want to [__] hear
that [__] the Chicago Cubs didn't win
for over aund [__]
years people born lived
died never saw him win
anything the bills have been around for
in the NFL since 1970 all right they're
53 [__] years in 54 years in quit
your [__]
whining you lose a game you take it like
a
man
breaking down crying in the stance what
is This World Cup
soccer you're an American you don't feel
feelings there's certain [__] groups
of people out there I know that they
don't cry I know they don't there's no
way Armenians if they lose a soccer game
break down and
cry that's just not in them Russians
there's just no [__] way all right
and it used to be
Americans okay you you didn't cry you
went home and you took it out on your
wife you snapped at your children that's
what you did you didn't just break down
and
cry is that the Chris Bosch effect did
he make it
okay or was that that other person there
was somebody that said it was okay to
cry about something and just film
themselves
[Laughter]
crying oh
[__] you know what I watched the other
day yesterday as I'm trying to get over
this
cold speaking of crying I put on the cry
tieron channel has tear in it too cry
tieron ion the cry tier ION channel and
I watched John
C Escape From New
York I hadn't watched
that I watched that on cable when it
came out in the mid 80s and I [__]
loved it I went back and I watched and
it was [__] it was great was
uh you
know I would say it kind of reminded me
of like
the road warrior or like the Terminator
in sort of the rawness of it but I feel
like those movies took from John
Carpenter style he kind of came up with
that first I didn't realize that guy
scored most of his own
movies had like a CIO keyboard and he
wrote like he wrote the theme to
Halloween that's pretty [__] iconic
right that's right up there with that
guy writing the theme to when you're
thinking about [__] on
Jeopardy
see you're speed it up it's the exact
same song I heard mg Griffin and John
Carpenter never spoke after that that's
true you can put that on the Wikipedia
page um no it was a [__] great movie
um [__] uh you know what's funny is I
when I was watching it and I was
thinking about Kurt
Russell and I was thinking how he did
that big TR in Little China I'm like
he's literally mocking his own
performance
in
uh Escape from New York and I was
thinking like I wonder if that pissed
John Carpenter off and then I saw that
John
Carpenter directed that movie also so
they were kind of making fun of this
genre of movies that they helped create
which I thought was really cool and both
of them totally worked because snake
pliskin is a total [__]
badass
and but this you know of course you can
look at a movie and make jokes about it
but like it's still a [__] great
movie but then Big Trouble in Little
China he was just sort of making fun of
that whole like leading
man action hero thing which I love too
right in the height of it
too not like looking back a decade later
like some hipster [__] you know what is
funny about hipsters is how they dressed
they they dress like you know sometimes
so you know the ones that dress like
they're in a period piece like
movie like the pick they dress like it's
the
1920s or whatever and
uh I was like weird like so you you
identified with that eror you know was
pretty wildly racist
1920 you know they're dressed up like
think I mean yeah let me tell you
something see Sports should be white for
whites only
yeah no I did not the ideology it's just
the
fashion
um
anyway so my wife's on me right now cuz
I'm not good when I'm sick like what I
do when I get sick is I just sort of
ignore
it and I just continue I go you know I
just keep doing whatever so she yelled
at me in a loving
way she looked at me and she gently
touched my face and she said listen you
bald orange
[__] okay go to the bedroom lay down
drink plenty of fluids and get over
this okay you're not playing drums
you're not going outside you're not
going to the movies you're not going to
go you
know how great are my options even when
I'm sick it's one of the great things
about becoming a standup comedian when
you're taking time off the
road is it's like you're a kid now like
summer
vacation except you're hemorrhaging cash
every
[Laughter]
day money never sleeps isn't that what
they say
um I hate that [__] phony deep [__]
money never sleeps rise and grind like
all of these these [__] things that
are supposed to sound deep and it's just
like no you have just 100% s bought into
capitalism that you're going to have
every day you have to wake up and just
work your ass off and if you don't like
you're somehow losing and you're going
to lose all of
it
um I swear to God like there there
should just be
like did I say this on the podcast they
should just have like a limit to the
amount of wealth that you can
attain just so you don't miss out on
life you know like just say whatever it
is $50 $100 million and then once you
get there you're able to just have $100
million you have $100 million you're
[__]
good you know the [__] do you need any
more of that right but then they but
they give you a sticker and it just said
I did it you know it's like having like
the black AMX or whatever the [__]
everybody wants you know I did
it I'm done are you yeah are you then
they like talking [__] so it still feeds
their
ego uh then they can all compete about
when they were
done you know I was done by the time I
was 36 so I was done by the time I was
34 yeah but you know you came from
[__] I'm done money right I'm a
self-made I'm dner right and you just
you're [__] done and then the rest of
the money that you make cuz some people
are just really good at making money
you
know but then what would you
do if you keep earning money and you
give it back to the system is so [__]
corrupt and then
also this whole thing about giving money
to poor people like they're all [__]
Saints you know poor people are just
like rich people some of them are cool
most of them are
[__]
so you'd have to educate
everybody on money and it just it just
you couldn't do it that's the thing man
you you literally cannot help somebody
out you can't help dumb people out
that's what I've
learned or stubborn people pigheaded
people you can't help narcissists
there's a there's so many different
factions of human beings that if you try
to help them out you just
can't because of the way that they're
wired you
know like I know some really smart
talented people in this business and you
literally just cannot help them out
because they're [__] fullon
narcissists or ego
maniacs and they can't take in any
information unless they feel like it
came from them or they figured it out or
whatever all right sorry just got a
phone call there uh I always forget to
put it on airplane mode
why would you put it on airplane mode
when you're sitting in your
house
um here's one for
you all right as you go into the world
two
things don't ever become part of
somebody's Entourage and don't [__]
interact with somebody that has an
Entourage don't waste your time with
that
person that's it all right I'm not going
to say oh maybe I say a little more on
yeah you
just just trust
me don't be in somebody's Entourage and
don't [__] with somebody that has an
Entourage and you will be
good all right anytime whatever [__]
business you're in and somebody rolls up
and there's like two or three SUVs
there's the dude you want to talk to and
then three other trucks of jerk offs
that's it like that person is not a
person anymore
they're just they're they're not
Tethered to reality cuz all of those
people the one person that they're all
underneath like that person's
like happiness becomes their currency
keep that thing happy and then we all
eat and then at that point nobody's
calling the person out on any of their
[__] they are no longer a somebody
that you could actually have a [__]
conversation with um there you
go that's a good
one
um you know what's you know was a good
one back in the day was when you went
over to somebody's house and you just
sort of took a glance at their
bookshelf and what books they were
reading you'd get an
idea and one time there was this [__]
sleazy ass manager that wanted to sign
me and I swear to God over his left
shoulder I'm taking a meeting with him
and he had a book on mind
control
I swear to God it said mind
control and and that guy obvious for
obvious
reasons I was not going to sign with
this
guy all right even though I did cuz I
didn't have any self-esteem I actually
I'm full of [__] I signed with I was
with him for a couple
years
um but I shouldn't have let's totally be
honest here
I [__] up uh which is what wisdom is
wisdom is what you learn through the
fuckups in your life and if you're not a
selfish bastard when you get old you
pass on this information to younger
people so they can avoid some of the
pitfalls that you stepped into and then
we all become better people isn't that
how it's supposed to work um anyway two
reasons why I shouldn't have signed one
that he's giving off this sleazy Vibe
and the obvious he's reading a book
called Mind Control which of course he
was not even good at
um and then
secondly the other reason he was like if
you're reading a book on mind control
and you're trying to [__] sign a
client you should probably be smart
enough not to have that on the
Shelf cuz if you do all you're going to
sign is low self-esteemed [__] idiots
well maybe that is right maybe what he
was doing was good maybe he maybe that
was his genius maybe he left it out
there you know that any anybody that has
self-esteem and sees this is going to
walk out but anyone who sees that and
still signs with me I'll be able to do
mind control all right well I work that
out anyway well learn from me if you're
taking a meeting with somebody and they
have a book on mind control don't get
into business with them you know and you
wouldn't think you'd have to tell people
that but I wish somebody told me
that oh
jeez so what do we got here we got the
Ravens we got the bill BS R not a Bills
sorry we got the
Chiefs the
Chiefs uh and then we got who else we
got the
49ers and the
Lions is it going to be a
rematch Ravens 49ers or Chiefs and
49ers what would I like to see I would
like to
see the Lions versus the Chiefs the
Lions
win or lion versus the
Ravens and uh I actually like the Ravens
I like both harbaughs I like the Raven
organization I like defensive minded
organizations like the Giants the
Ravens the Steelers it's kind of funny
the black and blue
division Bengals have a really good
defense Browns have a good defense you
know um historically speaking I like
those types of teams um all right so
what do I think's going to happen I
think it's going to be 49ers versus the
Chiefs
uh and I think the Chiefs are going to
win that's what I just think I just
think that the Chiefs are too well
coached and I just think that Patrick
momes Kelsey and and they they just they
know how to
win they know when to flip the [__] this
switch uh cuz on the Ravens should
win and then it should be Ravens 49ers
and on paper it should be the 49ers CU
they have the most Talent or whatever
but uh I think Brock p is still a little
bit
young uh we shall see that's you know
what that is guys hey you know it's just
my two cents that's all it is uh
hopefully I feel better I got to go do
some [__] standup I'm climbing the
[__] walls over here I went to go fly
I haven't flown in like [__] like two
weeks just been raining out here so I
finally go up there it's it's clear day
the day after it
rained usually a clear Day means you
know high winds that's why it's clear
you would you know hazy day people think
oh it's a bad day to fly it's actually
the haze is just hanging in the air
because it's nice and uh calm air you
know it's kind of sucks so so like when
you fly on the days you don't get tossed
around you can't you know see as much as
you would
like and on the crystal clear days
you're getting bounced around so of
course I go up to the airport and
there's no wind or
anything but I as I drive in though I
see the flag and it's [__]
blowing significantly it's not hanging
or dangling it's straight out and it's
blowing not violently but it's blowing
I'm like wow that's more wind than what
was at my
house and uh by the time I was done
pre-flighting it and fueling it up and
everything it was just like
you know the winds weren't bad it's the
gusts when you in a light aircraft it's
gusting that that just makes it not fun
so it was like 20 knots gusting up to 27
28 and it's just like all right I could
fly in this but it's not going to be fun
just getting thrown around up there so
anyway I do have it all pre-lighted so I
think this weekend I'm going to take it
up [__] dying to go flying there's a
couple things I want to check Che
out
um there's an old car museum in Oxnard
that's closing Johnny Cash's house up in
ohigh there's this killer [__] bowlan
alley you know from like the 1960s that
they haven't changed at all you go in
there looks like the Jetson I like doing
[__] like the Laie is such a [__]
interesting City when it comes to all of
that stuff so I definitely want to do
that um chomping at what do they call
chomping at the at the uh not the bit I
used to know what it was it's the thing
you stick in a horse's
mouth oh who the [__] knows uh
anyway let's do the reads here for this
week if I even got any I have no idea if
I've even received these
yet sounded oddly religious didn't
it do you accept the Lord Jesus Christ
and all of his teachings so help your
God whatever the [__] they say in all
those mob
movies what was that one do you do you
denounce Satan that was
Godfather I haven't seen that a long
time all right now I got to come off
airplane mode right I come off airplane
mode and then I go into my my my [__]
inbox and then it's there right and then
it's there and it's not there all right
[__] this we're going to wrap this
podcast up I'll do the I'll do the
uh I'll do the advertisements later oh
let me just do the I'll just do the
intro okay guys now it's time for the
live
reads Dad we're
back
um anyway uh you know what I can't
believe is F1 and Moto GP are going to
be starting up in like another month
[__] incredible how much they beat
this [__] out of their bodies and they
only give them like three months off and
then they're just like right back at
it uh the big thing is is Mark Marquez
is riding for ducatti I cannot [__]
believe
it uh I've always rooted against him and
Honda and rooted for davito and all
those
guys peka by all right all those guys
over at ducat ducatti and
uh I don't know now I don't know what to
do cuz I I love
Ducatis uh I like just all of that
Italian
[__] the food the cars the motorcycles
all of that stuff I've really been
wanting to go back to Europe though uh
I've become fascinated
with you
know I don't know just all of the
language and food and Cuisine over there
and how it just was through colonialism
over here in the British ideology and it
just became like you speak English [__]
all of this other stuff and then we all
had to kind of fall in line just like
any other country that Britain was
involved in it's really fascinating how
they did that and to this day how like
English is considered like the top
language or the only language or the
language of the world it's like why it's
it's no better or worse than any other
language
um
anyway like when I was growing up like
if someone couldn't speak English if
they spoke broken English like you
literally looked at them like they were
dumb like they were dumb because because
they couldn't speak English and even
though they could already speak another
language their language was dumb because
it wasn't English how [__] stupid was
that and that was the prevailing thought
when I was growing
up I grew up in a dumb
time guess what I fit right
in oh I fit right in well it's much as
my lovely wife told me not to go play
drums I'm going to lose my [__] mind
if I don't go downstairs
go out to the garage and [__] go
[__] play some drums I got to do it
I'm dying to do it uh she's not home
she's out busting her ass today so I
think I'm going to go do that all right
and that's basically it I still have
glass in my finger I still have a cold
the bills still have not won in the
postseason [__]
unbelievable uh but anyway I'm going to
head out tonight I'm going to do some
[__] stand up that's what I'm going
to do all right and and that is it and
that is it that's all I have to say
there's a bunch other [__] that I would
say but I'm not going to say it cuz I
don't believe in it what do you think
about that huh oh did I tell you I'm
Going Underground this year I'm Going
Underground I am not going to sit back
and watch these two mentally ill [__]
old ass white dudes run for [__]
president I'm just not going to sit
there and watch the entire country act
like their [__] idiot isn't a [__]
ID it's it's just
it's yeah I'm not watching
it you know it's going to be like the
[__] real
housewives uh except old
guys they should sponsor like Viagra
should like sponsor this year's
presidential
election brought to you by suncreen and
Viagra
um anyway I feel like maybe this will be
the last
time we have to deal with both these old
idiots and then I think hopefully it
would be amazing if we just went
youth uh and by youth I just meet
somebody 40 years old male or
female you
know we just we got to get out of
this how about a
40-year-old Asian chick like a [__]
39-year-old Puerto Rican dude just we
got to we got to shake this up this is
just
[__] this is just I don't know what
what are we
doing oh no what are we doing I mean
Jesus [__]
Christ we have a warmonger with dementia
going up against the reality show TV
star
again that's what I love it's not how
did we end up here this is happening
it's happening
again [__] wild it is [__]
wild and there's people that actually
have
passion for either one of those
candidates like I get it you towing in
the company line but to actually be
passionately for one or the other just
[__] blows my mind this is just my
two cents here all right I think I've
said enough uh uh that is it uh but you
can go out you have yourself a good day
today and you go out you be nice to
somebody you know regardless of their
[__] uh political leadings or
whatever that's it I think that's the
only solution it's just regular people
we just have to be nice to each other we
got to stop watching this [__] H I don't
I don't have any solutions I have no
idea I have no idea but uh I'm looking
forward to being back on the road and
you guys if you're nice enough to show
up to my shows making you laugh because
that's what fills me up that's it that's
all I got all right go [__] yourselves
have a great weekend your [__] and I'll
talk to you on
[Music]
Monday hey what's going on it's Bill
Burr and it's time for the Monday
Morning podcast for
Monday uh January 25th
2016 what's going on how are you how are
you oh know how I'm doing I'm not doing
good oh everybody in Denver is settling
in with a big [__] smile on your face
aren't you huh you [__] potm smoking
[__] with your goddamn hemp ponchos um
congratulations to the Broncos they
deserved it right out of the gate you
know we took the ball they stopped us
and I remember when they scored in the
first drive I was like that was
disturbingly
easy
um and uh you know they just we have
they just Von [__] Miller I mean if
the if he was in the back field any
quicker during the game he'd be taking
the [__] snap I mean it was brutal we
just didn't have any answers on the
offensive
blood and uh that's what did it not the
[__] field goal and not us going
forward on fourth down I can't only
imagine what they're saying on I'm doing
this Sunday night I can imagine on the
Sports Talk Radio that they're second
guessing bill bellich yeah second guess
him yeah second guess him it's just bill
bellich oh what are you yeah you're the
other
[__] you've never coached on any
[__] level I'll tell you right now
why did they they should have kick the
field goal they would they would have
been in by five and they gr catches a
touchdown P they're up by
[__] I love how people think
like like something earlier in the game
if they just did this that that that
doesn't change everything after that I
mean how many [__] back to the
Futures do they have to make that you
see if you change one thing that it
changes everything else so if the
Patriots did kick the [__] thing and
we got to within five and when we got
the ball back the fact that a touchdown
would put us ahead rather than us being
down by eight they would have had a
completely different [__]
defense okay before they [__] do all
of that second guessing [__] you know
[__] verie was was going dude I
thought I said I was saying I was saying
when they did it was dumb oh did you
non- coach verie yeah I'm going to
listen to you as opposed to to to
[__]
bellich um when they did it I was like I
love the I love the call going forward
we weren't able to move the [__] ball
at all on offense the entire [__]
game we were the only reason why we had
a touchdown was because they had that
[__]
lateral and even then then we missed a
[__] extra point it just it wasn't
our day even when we had got a gift we
[__] it up and then we gave it right
back with a pick and then they scored
but um yeah we weren't able to move the
[__] ball every time Brady went back
there was somebody in his
face you know chomping at the [__]
his his legs as he was trying to throw
the [__] thing you're that close I I
I agreed with going for it it didn't
work out but you know that's how life is
sometimes so um but it was a great
season and um for what they accomplished
with all the injuries and all that type
of [__] it was amazing and uh I got to
tell you I am um I'm definitely rooting
for uh pton Manning I'd like to see him
go out like John Elway it'd be pretty
cool for another
guy in the Broncos does that but uh then
you also you got to love Cam Newton you
know Jesus Christ the only thing I don't
like about Cam Newton is one more person
tells me there's nobody having more fun
than him I tell you right now there's
nobody having more fun than Cam Newton
Cam new he's like a kid on Christmas
he's like a he's like a kid with his
second birthday he's like it's like I
get
it he's having fun he's also totally
[__] haming it up and making sure his
next sneaker deal would be will be even
10 times what the [__] he has right now
let's not just let's not be totally
naive here and just act like everything
he's doing is just because he loves
playing the game he wasn't this [__]
animated when he was at uh uh [__]
Auburn I used to watch those games roote
against Alabama I used to root against
them so I would watch and I was I he he
wasn't doing all that [__] but then
again he couldn't get paid or at least
legally he couldn't get paid back then
so you know what was the point
or dance it every time he [__] I love
when that one guy [__] uh they they
threw the screen pass and he ran all the
way to the other side of the field by
the time he gets there Cam Newton runs
in with him and kind of [__] jumps in
on that guy's Super Bowl uh super his
touchdown celiv
celebration and then the cameraman is
just following Cam Newton for the rest
of the time and
um in my uh in my business that's
uh that's called uh not not stealing
aine it's called uh ah Jesus Christ I
don't do enough acting to even know
stealing aine is when you're better than
the other person upstaging somebody he
was upstaging him so um I I just don't
need anybody else telling me how much
fun Cam Newton's having I get it he's
having a good time but he's also
completely Hamming it up because when he
does he makes a zillion dollars however
it's crushing as the Patriots loss was
like I
literally had to I had to go for a walk
after they lost um and I got to tell you
I felt like we were going to lose that
game you know sometime in the second
quarter I was just like this I can feel
it this just isn't our day it just
wasn't Brady never I mean they were all
over him he never got comfortable and uh
he wasn't screaming and yelling and
getting people going I thought but our
[__] defense played
great um but I just I don't know you
just sometimes you just feel it it's
just not your [__] day so I literally
had to go for a walk I went to the the
bank I mailed something I got the car
washed there was like nobody there it
was like a ghost town it was just like
you know some [__] nerds or whatever
who don't give a [__] about sports and
some poor bastards who had to work and
um yeah I went to the car wash and then
I went to this
uh uh I don't know Mediterranean Middle
Eastern whatever the [__] it is got one
of those WS the schwam wraps whatever
the [__] you call it and it actually
worked out perfectly I walked a few
blocks over I got the wrap I ate it I
watched some of the Carolina Arizona
Game and then when I came back right as
I came back the guy was finishing my car
and he put his hand up like go whose car
is this was [__] perfect perfect
timing um that was about the only uh
good thing that happened during those
three hours of watching that [__]
game but
um anyways I got to tell you as as
bad as
um as bad as the the feeling I had when
the Patriots lost
um the one thing that cheered me up was
watching that Carolina fan fall out of
the [__] stance that was one of the
funniest [__] things I've seen in a
long time he just completely he missed
timed when the player was coming down I
think he I think he just ran down and he
just m misjudged where the rail was and
he just slammed into it and just went
right up and over straight up and
over I mean if you if you put a coat
rack on Wheels it would have landed
lighter than this guy I did there was
just nothing athletic about him it was
just all [__] was it inertia is that
the proper physics term he just ran down
I just wish I could have heard his
thoughts when he was at the Tipping
Point when his legs were right up were
pointing at the 12 and his head was at
6:00 right as it started to come around
to about
11:45 you know he was lying to himself
hanging on the rail like I got this i
got this ah [__] oh the stupid dad jeans
just is shooting up in the air right
from the Gap and just [__] lands on
the ground I liked when he got up too
and then he tried to like climb back up
in the stands and that dude was there
like H nobody what why don't you just
walk around we don't need you falling
down again
um I'll tell you what the funny thing is
is you know there's going to be some
lawyer scaring the [__] out of the owner
of that team that emotionless Maniac
that they kept cutting to when he would
just be sitting there like he was
listening to the verdict of his own
murder trial
um the [__] is with that
guy is he just focused on the Super Bowl
everybody in his Luxury Box is going
nuts he's got his [__] furred up uh
wife that's when you know you got money
when your wife has a fur coat and hasn't
been spray painted you know that's when
you know that it's that you guys are
living a level of wealth that you don't
even run into commoners do you you know
there's always some [__] that's got to
come along and [__] spray paint
somebody's fur coat which I've never
understood
it's like the animal died and now you're
just going to throw out its hide at
least it was a jacket you know what I
mean like if somebody came and killed me
and made a jacket out of me I I wouldn't
want you to spray paint it you know then
they're just going to throw it out then
I'm just like a [__] jacket you know
in a landfill right floating in the
ocean let the [__] walk around with
it um anyways Jesus [__] Christ
I'll tell you right now nobody's having
more fun in the National Football
League oh God I was watching the game
with a buddy of mine we were just
throwing out the cliches I'll he gets he
gets here he's the first one here and
he's the last one to leave I'll tell you
right now you give me 22 guys like that
and I could coach this state to a Super
Bowl I'll tell you right now you have to
know where you are on the field why
would you run a 5y route when you need
six yards for a first down I mean that
just doesn't make any
sense I'll tell you out there they are
just they're just having fun out there
they're just having fun that's what this
game's all about they're out there they
loose he's just out there slinging
it um anyways and just like that my
[__] football season is over so who
do you like in the Super
Bowl I'll tell you what I don't like
have you seen that [__] advertisement
for Super Bowl 50 the in gold and for
whatever reason there's this woman
standing
there looking like the hot chick that
walks in in some gume movie from the
[__] 1940s she's standing there in a
ran coat and high heels with like a
golden
umbrella telling you it's it's over it's
[__]
over the bills hired a uh I don't know
what they hired they had a woman for
some job over it's [__] over it's
done it's done those three hours where
you could get away as a married guy you
could just get away for three hours it's
it's it's over it's I I it's going to
sound like the Westminster dog
show in about seven years you know we
had a great run we had a great
run and now it's over you know but it's
our own damn faults it's our own damn
faults you know what it was we just
couldn't hide the joy we were having
watching football without him we
couldn't hide the joy and there's
nothing that annoys a [__] woman like
a bunch of guys going and having a good
time without him so they're in they're
dressing in pink for a [__] month
it's it's [__] it's [__]
over
H I wish I just knew I just knew I wish
I knew that it was going to come to this
I would have tried to
enjoy you know my first 37 38 years of
football I they just flew by I would
have tried to enjoy him a little bit
more and now it's
over we should make a trade this is what
we should do we should just trade him
the WNBA just go like what if we just
give you a league that we started it'll
be almost like a divorce where you just
get it even though you didn't do
anything or maybe you like emotionally
supported the guy or some [__] or
whatever the [__] you say at the court
right you just give them the WNBA you
can be the commissioners all the owners
the commentators the refs you can be
everybody in the stands we'll give you
your section of Buffalo Wild Wings you
know just just don't take NFL football
from us can you can you just not just
can you give us can you just leave us
with that can we just have
that oh God maybe I'm just too old to
understand
it coach can you tell us what happened
there in the first half well you know we
weren't getting it done and we got to
get out there maybe uh try to have a
little you know I'll tell you right now
nobody's having more fun than me I just
don't know if I'm ready for
that you know I don't
know I just you I I don't know where do
you go
now I guess I guess the only place left
is you you you become one of those weird
old guys that plays chess in the
park you know what it is about Chess
it's boring and quiet enough that they
don't notice that you're over there
without them enjoying
yourself you
know that's the genius you ever see a
guy who's been married for like 50 years
like the genius of them I swear to God
the genius of them is they [__] they
know how to have a good time without
their wife
noticing so it doesn't Peak your
interest right she's [__] over in the
quiet she doesn't give a [__] right but
young guys we're idiots OT we come home
with a big grin on our face talking
about how awesome it was blah blah and
all they hear is this [__] had
the
nerve to go out for three hours and not
miss me and not think about
me well we'll see about that won't
we
um it's [__]
over ah it's over just like the Patriots
season so who do you guys like in the
um who do you guys like in the
uh I'm trying to think of an activity
that women do what what [__] group
that they have that I would like to
infiltrate and I for the life of me I
can't think of it you know what they got
the the the 4H
club girl
scouting
um any of those feminist groups that'd
be a funny thing to
join join one of those [__] groups
and act like you're a feminist you just
go down there and you say like the most
ignorant but like yet it's still Pro
women
[__] come down there with a [__] bud
tall yeah I just wanted to say you know
I came down here to support you brds you
know I think it's uh I think it's [__]
up the way the guy treat you you know
just cuz you run around with the skirt
and it takes you long to get ready
doesn't mean you can't run the company
right am I right ladies come
on uh bill um we really appreciate you
coming down here we think what you're
saying is POS positive we just just some
buzzword here that we uh put into a
spreadsheet uh little pamphlet thing
that we'd like you to look at maybe you
could not say them the next meeting
maybe take a couple of weeks off oh no
no I'm showing up every
week wait for him to kick me out then I
assume for being
sexist um I'm just a grumpy old man
that's all it is I a grumpy old man who
wants things to stay the
same you know do I make any money off
the NFL I don't I do have the m mute
button you got to you got to love the
mute button anytime they cut to the
chick on the sideline I just [__] it I
hit mute you know just trying to
to keep it going you
know just for another couple more
weeks how come we can't blah blah blah
and okay all right Jesus Christ I think
it really comes I what are you going to
do it's you know it's [__]
over it's our own goddamn faults we just
had too much [__] fun without
so you know the next thing we
start just you come home you you you
tone it down you [__] tone it down um
anyways let's plow ahead here so I still
haven't even said what is it the uh
Super Bowl who do you like Panthers or
Broncos you know I was impressed that
the Panthers [__] were kicking the
[__] out of Arizona and they didn't take
their foot off the gas pedal this
week
um I don't know but the Broncos have
that [__] defense but our offensive
line stinks it's doesn't stink we just
banged up so I don't know I don't know
how good the
uh I don't
know I don't you know what I don't even
[__] know I'm still so [__]
annoyed by that
goddamn the finality of not even that we
lost CU I felt Denver was the better
[__] team godamn
[__] all right that's it plowing
oh by the way did I mention I saw uh the
hateful eight did anybody see
that did anybody see the hateful late I
can't remember if I talked about it I
saw it in 70
mm at the ark light here in uh in Los
Angeles um it had an intermission and it
had an O overture in the beginning there
were no Coming Attractions cuz who the
[__] going to shoot that 70 mm right
and I absolutely [__] Lov that movie
from start to finish I love the pacing
of it I I love the whole I just
loved I loved
it I just the whole [__] it was just an
experience like Tarantino was like I
don't give a [__] about your cell phone
how you your [__] brain is all
scrambled now cuz you're looking at an
iPad screen all goddamn day long I don't
give a
[__] the movie is this long this is the
movie I wanted to make and you can
settle the [__] in or leave
was it just an experience I absolutely
[__] love that movie um oh speaking
of speaking of iPads you see when the
Patriots iPads went out that was strange
huh did the Broncos go out is that weird
that's just one of those strange things
just one of those fluke things that
happen to happen and uh it's all good
it's all good cuz it happened to the
Patriots now had it happened the other
way around and it was in our Stadium oh
Jesus how many months would ESPN talk
about that you know versy called me
today instead of former quarterback back
I think it was for the Giants I don't
even know was saying like yeah we used
take air out of the ball all the [__]
time everybody did it and everybody does
it once again and I know you guys are
like on Jesus Bill how long are you
going to harp on this well they talked
about it for [__] eight months you
know I think since you know the judge
threw it out of court I mean it hasn't
been eight months since then has it
September October November December
January you got another three months of
this
[__] um
anyways enough of that [__] I uh oh by
the way I started that that um that
series top boy T boy on uh Netflix and
uh [__] great show two episodes in
enjoying it but Jesus Christ you got to
put on the [__]
subtitles good Lord mumbling fast as
[__] it's almost as bad as pey blinders
but pey blinders you can understand the
[__] was supposed to happen like a 100
years ago this [__] here is far far as I
can tell it's supposed to be going on
right now and I still can't understand
them I don't think they say in it
enough um stamps.com everybody here we
go a little advertising for this week
um all right here we go you know it' be
cool though if there was like a female
like Vince Lombardi who came in you know
what I mean and she had the exact same
like like
demeanor grab grab grab nobody tackling
out
there what the hell's going on
today will be the greatest day of your
life believe
it you
know they'll
start they'll have their classic
Saints all right everybody grab a towel
cover your dicks
let's let's focus on next
week um oh by the way uh I want to thank
uh uh Brian tishy for let me be a part
of the bonso bash this past Friday night
I got to go down there and co-host it
with him and uh just the amount of
drummers that I saw that night and I got
to stand behind them if there's any
YouTube video you're going to see my
dumb [__] head just staring at their
bass drum foot um these are some of the
guys that played last Friday night
stevenh Perkins James addiction Chad
Smith from the Chili Peppers Dave
Lombardo from dead cross and uh Slayer
um who else I'm going for memory um oh
there's a guy that uh Greg Potter from
the Buddy Rich band guy plays in the
Buddy Rich band and crushed a Zeppelin
song that's pretty much running the
gamut Simon Wright last time I saw Simon
Wright play a song on the who made
hoor uh Rober Fuso from skid R last time
I saw him they opened for aosmith New
Year's Eve 1989 December 31st at the
Boston got
it um will Calhoun was there Brad
Whitford from aosmith Carmen uh
aacy oh my God uh Ray lzir from corn
absolutely destroyed ail's last fan this
guy John hmel I never heard of [__]
destroyed cashmere just so many [__]
amazing drummers and I actually got to
sit in which is [__] hilarious I got
to sit in in between guys at that level
uh I played that song off of uh the
presence album for your love and uh I'm
sorry for your love for your life and
uh I want to thank uh everyone in the
Moby Dicks for helping walk me through
that
song
um you know you know what it was I
[__] up a lot during the song but I
nailed the arrangement as far as like
all the changes I was on it for that and
I find that if you do that that people
in the crowd don't notice that you're
[__] up the fills there was like one
big fill and I [__] rimmed out on the
thing I was so [__]
pissed um what are you going to do but
it was uh it was just a [__] amazing
night and uh four hours [__] long
watching these guys and they had this
botom [__] vistalite set the exact
same style kit that he had um if you
watch the song and The Song Remains the
Same and this the [__] kick drum was
wide open they had nothing in there they
didn't even have a felt strip going
across it it was one of the sickest
sounds I've ever heard in my life big 26
inch kit they had the two tonies to the
left of the high hat and then the
[__] gong and it's I'm so pissed at
the end of the song I didn't hit the
[__] gong how many [__]
opportunities do you get to do that and
I blew it but
um I just had I just had the best time
doing it and uh then of course I'm
driving home it was down in Anaheim and
I'm driving home and the best thing
about driving home at night in La is
there's finally no traffic and I'm
[__]
Cruising and uh all of a sudden the
[__] five just comes to a grinding
Halt and three four lanes merge down to
one and then are forced off of the
highway into like a
neighborhood uh because the only time
they obviously that they can fix the
highways is at night so I have
empathy for these state workers out here
but um sucked for me and I I complet I
had like a [__] meltdown for about 5
minutes and I was texting everyone that
I got a number from that was on the show
telling them not to get on the
five and uh [__] brutal and once
again I just don't understand why people
buy fast cars out here unless you have a
pickup truck with a trailer and you can
drive that car you can tow the car to a
racetrack I just don't
understand you know these [__] cars
you see out here that can go like 180
160 200 miles hour some of these [__]
cars it's like where are you doing
that I don't know it's [__]
ridiculous I beeped at this lady today I
was probably a dick I just really I
can't [__] stand people when they sit
at a goddamn red light you're right
behind them and then when the light
turns green they put on their [__]
left turn signal and then you beep at
him they're like what the [__] it's like
give me a heads up give me a heads up so
I could have backed off and gone around
you you [__] dick now the 20 people
behind me are going to go by I'm going
to miss the [__] light now I'm on
your
schedule you know like that that's never
happened to you you've never been the
person behind that person you don't
[__] remember now you're first in
line you just say [__] it
sorry most of this [__] everything that
I'm saying women in the NFL all of this
[__] most of this [__] has nothing to do
with the it has to do with the fact that
my team lost you know so now I'm just
[__] grumpy
um
anyways today would be the best day of
your life but only if you
win let's win one for the Kipper
um all right oh hey I'm going to be be
playing out live again if you guys uh
and you would standup oh Dean Del re
Dean Del re's uh 50th birthday you got
to come down to this at the lray theater
Del r at the
lray uh it's going to be an unbelievable
[__] lineup of uh Comedians and
musicians to celebrate Dean Del re's
50th birthday and of course my [__]
internet cuts out I finally had the
[__] thing finally had it I had it
all [__] lined up I was ready to read
off the whole thing and what happens it
just [__] disappears you [__] [__]
all right well this is what I know um
Joe Rogan's going to be doing some
standup there uh I will be on it
crystalia let me get to the flyer here
let me get to the
flyer there it is there's the flyer all
right Brian redband Joe
bartnik
roseb tailgate Legend Joe bartnik Dean
Del re is going to be there and uh after
we do a bunch of standup uh we're going
to do some uh from what I heard there's
going to be all these musicians there
and they're going to play the entire
Highway to Hell
album uh Rudy Saro is going to be
there from uh Aussie
Osborne uh Dave Kushner from Velvet
Revolver and the guy who does the music
for F is for family Dave Lombardo Tracy
guns gilby clack from Guns and Roses
it's going to be [__] sick it's going
to be it's going to be a lot of fun um
so come on down uh February 2nd you can
get tickets at uh goldenvoice
decom um all right let's uh let's
continue on here with with the uh with
the podcast what else did I want to talk
about is there anything anything at all
as I if I as I settle into the fact
that my [__] football season is over
um oh Jesus Christ the Patrice O'Neal
benefit how the [__] did I almost forget
that uh Lake gray Patrice O'Neal the I
think this is the fourth one we've
done um yeah 13 14 15 16 yeah this is
the fourth one it's already flying by um
it's sold out there will be a few
tickets released at the um right before
the show starts it's always a few people
that requested tickets and then they
don't show up so there's a chance if you
walk up there might be uh some tickets
it's going to be an amazing lineup and
as always uh other than the money that
we use to uh pay to rent out the theater
all monies goes to uh patrice's loved
ones and it's really made an
unbelievably
positive effect on their lives um you
know his mom has been able to get a
condo and his stepdaughters is going to
private school sense the benefit and uh
um just the quality of their lives
basically stayed the same you know
Patrice was taking care of them so um
it's really it's the greatest thing that
I'm involved in during the course of the
year and I'm so happy that you guys step
it up every year and um buy tickets so I
want to thank everybody who bought
tickets it means the world to me and
everybody involved and all the comics
that take time out of their schedule to
come down there and um and perform and
it's just a it's just an awesome thing
and we're just going to keep doing it as
long as you guys keep showing up all
right so thank you thank you for that
and with that let's get into some of the
reads here for uh for this week all
right what are we up to here 33 minutes
all right all right all right hacky hate
hey Bill how are you he says I am not a
Patriots fan I am a DieHard Bears fan
after the Patriots lost all I saw on
Facebook was people trashing Brady and
bringing up Trump and deflate
gate I get it they're on most they're on
top most of the time and people love to
trash him or whoever is winning it life
now let's stop giving excuses to these
pansy ass [__] sports fan who spent
sports fans who spend 90% of their
[__] time talking about gossip it all
gets classified under gossip every hack
who was who was a static that the pastri
is lost is an [__] especially the
ones who will declare they could care
less about sports congrats you're about
as cool as the guy who paints his face
the only time I talk [__] about the
Patriots is to remind them of 1985 even
that's pretty weak go
Bears um yeah but you know if you're on
top you got to expect that people are
going to give your [__] um the only
thing I didn't like was was when the the
uh Broncos defense you know oh we're
getting sick of heing about Tom Brady
it's like well then win a [__] Super
Bowl win four of them and they'll talk
about you the Patriots never talk [__]
about the
Broncos they never said that they were
better than the Broncos and I also love
too it's just like you know they were
favorites they were F like the Patriots
made themselves favorites that you know
what's really overrated is is being a
favorite or being an underdog has
nothing to
do with your team it has to do with the
[__] dope in the Buffalo Wild Wings
who's betting on games all right what
Vegas tries to do is they try to get
money on both sides of the ball so they
try to pick a number all right that's
going to entice people to go 5050 that's
why the line changes during the course
of the week did one team get better or
another team get get worse I mean if
there's an injury yes but generally
speaking no what happens is is there's
too much money going to one side so they
need to entice people to come back the
other side because if if you know the
you can't have like 90% of the money on
one side of the ball that could
completely [__] over the gambling ring
or the uh they don't like those odds and
because ties lose that's enough to tip
it in their [__] favor that's
basically what goes on which is
why you know if you look back in ' 07
when the Patriots beat the Giants the
last game of the year and the Giants put
up like [__] 33 or 34 points and we
only won by like three or something
that's why like a month later we were
still 14-point
favorites it had all the Patriots are
overhyped they weren't overhyped what
happened was the Super Bowl brings out
people who don't know [__] about
football all right it brings out the
[__] ladies it brings out all you
know there's nothing worse than a Super
Bowl party if you give a [__] about
football if you really like the Super
Bowl if you really like football if
you're really football fan you watch it
alone or you watch it with like two or
three other people that keep their
[__] mouth shut right um but what
happens is during the Super Bowl that
brings out all the [__]
the novice fans that people don't even
watch and all they see is 18 and0
[__] are they know Brady like they
know they know Tom Brady the way I know
Darth Vader all right I can't tell you a
[__]
thing about the last like I don't even
know how many there's been since the
original Three I know Vader is [__]
Luke's father and that [__]
uh Luke and Leia are brother and sister
and that they kind of had like sexual
tension and wanted to [__] each other in
the beginning which I think is a really
weird thing to put into a kids movie
don't
you
um maybe he didn't know that when he
initially wrote it and then he just
needed a good left turn when he was
writing the second one I have no [__]
idea but I think the way he tried to
make it up was with those Geral in the
third one you know going W whatever the
[__] they did you know I know what the
[__] they did so anyway so that's as
much as I as much as I know about Star
Wars these people know about football so
then they come in they go to Vegas and
everybody goes in and thinks that
they're [__] Sean connory and James
Bond right they wa you know they [__]
go down there and they got some I'm in
Vegas suit on their wife's wearing some
[__] you know sparkly number and
everybody's out there you know stepping
outside of themselves and it's say I
want to gamble I want to get in the
action who's playing I don't know who
that other team is I know Tom Brady is
let me uh let me put a 100 bucks on his
on the Cliff of his [__] chin and
that's how the line goes
from what it should be about 3 Four
Points to all the way up to 14 that's
what the [__] happens all right and that
was for everybody who doesn't [__]
gamble okay all right Bill enough
already we get it your team lost and
you're [__] you're in a CUNY
mood um thank God that guy fell out of
the stance he didn't even look that
drunk I just loved his [__] Gap jeans
just [__] straight up in the air all
right next question here um oh by the
way way if you'd like to donate to this
podcast um all you got to do is just go
to uh next time you go to Amazon if next
time you're going to buy something on
that uh just go to my website Bill
bird.com click on the podcast page and
then you just click on the Amazon link
it just takes you there it doesn't cost
you any extra money um you might you
know later on in life if your index
finger wears out you might think like
you know what if I didn't do those extra
two clicks with my index finger U maybe
I would have had another 10 minutes of
joy and no [__] constant pain in my
index finger other than that there's
really nothing I even do it I even go
when I go to Amazon well why wouldn't I
I guess I get the money right you when I
did I went on there and I fixed my
[__]
cooler I don't know what the [__]
happened to my cooler this year at the
Rose bolt it's been to every rose bow
that I've been to and I've been to eight
of them at this point and I never had a
[__] problem and at some point like
my cooler basically it opens up to a
point you know you know the hinges stop
it from opening and then there's a strap
to keep it from going any further and I
don't know what
happened
um cuz I I [__] passed out like at
like 10:00 in the morning
so and I didn't even notice that my
cooler was [__] up but at the end of
the night when I got my cooler back the
uh it had basically been decapitated the
strap was busted and the hinges were
busted and I was like what the [__] what
happened you know it's like the Hulk
opened the thing up or something just
like just open it a little it's fine
then I was thinking when I fell down was
I was drunk did I land on the cooler and
it's like no I I wouldn't noticed that I
landed flat on my I landed like that
[__] guy when he fell out of the
stands that's how I fell I fell on the
grass do you realize I was on a fairway
a straight fairway golf course and I
lost my balance and fell down that's how
[__] drunk I was and you know what it
was [__]
great um so anyways I went to
uh oh actually I didn't go to Amazon I
just looked up Igloo um cooler repair
kit and they got like there's two
different kinds of hinges and I
accidentally ordered two of them and I
only need one of them so I have an extra
repair kit and I know you know the odds
and they they send you like three sets
of hinges you know if you have like the
the giant one you know the person who
kills his wife and doesn't want anybody
to know and just says she's on vacation
and he cuts her up like they have that
size hinge for that cooler and then they
just got you know the happy drunk that
falls down on New Year's Day you know so
they come with three sets of hinges for
each so I have an entire extra one so
anybody out there who has like a a
cooler that needs to be replaced it
comes with everything even like the
drain little drain hole [__] spout
thing it's got that um the strap does
come separately I don't have an extra
strap but I have an extra uh repair kit
so if anybody wants it send us an email
with an address and I'll send it out to
you cuz what what else am I going to do
with it I'm not going to throw it out
and someday if I ever
move
um you know I got to pack up something
that I I don't even [__] need
so there you go oh by the way
uh I'm still in the running here to
maybe get this drum room made SL podcast
room in the back of my garage um as
always there's major major [__]
structural issues but
um
I don't know just I I gota I got to sh
up that part of the house but there's
there's all these there's all these
[__] issues that I can't even talk
about because you know I'm getting a
permit I'm doing all of that [__]
[__] I know some of you like oh you
don't need a [__] permit if uh if
you're building within the structure if
you're not adding any square footage I
know all that [__] but like I you
know anytime you start hammering in your
[__]
garage your neighbors hear it they
[__] rat you out I just don't need
the [__] headache so I doing my due
diligence and it's taking a long time
but um I'm going to I'm going to make
this I'm going to make this [__]
happen and I have a
71 lwood green Sparkle all bottom siiz
drums and I'm going to make sure that
they [__] fit in there and I'm going
to [__] I don't give a [__] what do I
care
right you know the oceans are all fished
out the government takes all your
[__] money you know I don't give a
[__] F I'm going all out with this thing
this thing I'm literally going to be
able to I'm going to tell this guy if if
I'm able to do this and I'm not going to
have a [__] problem legally and I can
build the [__] thing I want to build
I'm literally going to be able to play
at 2:00 in the [__] morning and no
one's even going to hear it they might
it might sound like a Stereos on really
low um but I'd never be a douche enough
to play then um at least
sober that'll be great then right
anytime I'm bugging my wife I can just
walk out the back door go into my garage
sit down and put on a zeppelin album
Guns and Roses [__] uh all my [__]
[__] I listen to when I was growing
up Queens of the Stone Age you
know what what what else do you [__]
need oh you know what else I need I need
a bar out there right flat screen
TV you know what's funny about a man
cave when somebody really goes throws
down in their [__] man cave all I
hear is I am not happily married
and what you're doing is you're building
a mini version of what your life would
look like if you weren't what your house
would look like if you weren't married
like after you show them the house with
all the throw pillows and all the
[__] popery and all that [__] you
bring your buddy out to the garage and
you're just like yeah if I wasn't
married like this is what it would look
like but you know what's funny about
that I'm old enough to know that if your
house did look like
that the I I see the loneliness in
it cuz the bottom line is a manave what
it is is
like what you're building is what you
wish you had you wish you could afford
when you were [__] 22 years old
that's basically it and the problem is
is if you do it honestly if you actually
work your balls off you know and you
don't steal from anybody or any of that
[__] [__] it's going to take you to
you're about 50 unless you're one of
these [__] nerds in Silicone Valley
that comes up with an app or some [__]
you know you really don't get paid until
you get close to 50 that's just how it
is you know it's just how it is except
for Cam Newton he's getting paid I'll
tell you right now nobody's having more
fun than that guy if you look up fun in
the
dictionary
um anyways I
um yeah I'm going to [__] make a
little podcast thing I mean I don't have
a lot of
room but uh I'm going to I'm I'm going
to [__] do it upright and uh you know
getting back and taking lessons again
dude the [__] that I'm actually paying
attention to now that I never paid
attention to how I hold on to the sticks
where I'm hitting the snare drum my
balance all of that [__] used to be all
about going on YouTube seeing some guy
do one of those gospel chop [__]
licks and I'm going to go down here and
[__] just do this for [__] nine
days in a row and then I'll be able to
do that you know pull this fill off next
time I walk into guitar Car Center and
uh and then meanwhile all my other
playing sucked and uh I've just had
this total
Epiphany about all of it and uh it's
funny I'm not doing nearly as much as I
used to do but I think I'm playing
better than I ever played and uh I don't
know it's [__] exciting gives me a
reason to get up in the morning you know
so anyways let's move on to the next
question
here uh oh my god did I tell you guys
how I butchered that [__] pork pork
chop meal that I made H still sick over
that I'm like I'm eating pork chops
again this week cuz I have to redeem
myself all right so the hacky hate thing
yeah that just kind of comes with
winning games or whatever um all right
no Asian diversity at the Oscars Bill
hello from Canada would love to hear
what your take is on why no one's
complaining about the lack of Asians at
the Oscars oh you [__] that's
the bit I was going to do that was the
bit I was going to do yeah
that's it's as he goes as an asan I
don't care because a I suspect we aren't
producing good enough [__] not to not oh
wait we're not producing good enough
[__] not because we're Asian B Asians
aren't getting sweet roles because I'm
not profitable they aren't going to cast
an Asian parenthesis or black or female
actor that would make more money out of
some white
conspiracy dude you had like [__] two
sets of parentheses in there Asians
aren't getting sweet roles because it's
not
profitable they aren't going they they
aren't going to not cast an
Asian or black or female
actor that oh I see what you're saying
they're not they aren't going to not
cast an Asian actor that would make more
money out of some white conspiracy so
you're saying if they if they would make
them money then they would see who cares
if you don't like how the Oscars Define
the best
whatever I don't get
why and then that's the end of it I see
what you're saying well yeah you're
looking at it from a very
uh like money like I think that's a lot
of times sometimes you know it looks
like it's racism a lot of times it's
just money but what I
think American Cinema is finally
realizing is that there's a whole bunch
of other people in the world that they
can actually get money from if they gave
a [__] to make a movie that would appeal
to them and the only think reason why I
think they're doing that is because
everybody stole movies and it's so hard
to make money off of them now and there
such a big [__] risk because what
happened to the music
business has happened slash is happening
to the movie business right now which is
why there's really no more like from
like $20 million to like $70 million
they don't make movies in that bu
anymore they just don't it's either like
some [__] hundred million Star Wars
action hero movie or it's like [__]
below $10 million it seems um all the
way down to like a 100 Grand like Indie
sort of you know micro budget [__]
thing
um so yeah I see what you're saying yeah
I mean yeah there's no agents there
either where's the outcry for that well
people don't people give a [__] about
themselves that's the one thing that I
can say about people in general straight
across the board you know which is why I
guess white people need because they're
running [__] quote running [__] you know
what I mean like they're all cooperating
with one another because there's white
people in those positions they need to
take the time to actually give a [__]
about other stuff because I gotta be
honest with you I thought that kid that
played e in uh Straight Out of Compton
he should have got nominated he was he
was the [__] [__] in that movie I
should know that actor's name he was you
know what God God damn it why don't I
step outside my
whiteness I'm going to I'm going to set
the example here right now and I'll tell
you right now there's nobody having more
fun right now going on the internet than
this guy you look up fun on the internet
there'll be a picture of me Easy E
actor
um Eric Lin Wright is here Jason
Mitchell on playing EAS that [__] guy
was he should have got something even
get a Golden Globe did he get nominated
for
that um that was one of those movies
that I actually didn't even want to see
there was some line that what's his face
uh um gmti said you know what I mean you
can't trade him like that that when he
yelled whatever the [__] he yell like oh
Jesus Christ this this looks really
heavy-handed you know what I mean and
then they always have to have the uh you
know they always have to have the white
white angel in those movies when they
show racism so then white people will go
so they can lie to themselves and be
like yeah if I was there that's the
white guy I would be I'd be the angel
white guy I wouldn't be the the uh you
know the racist
guy um yeah know it's a very it's a very
interesting the whole [__] thing is
is really
uh interesting I don't know I have no
idea I mean I think you shouldn't just
say look black actors should be nomin
you should [__] then back it
up you know what I mean and give shout
outs to people that [__] deserve it
you should be like Jason Mitchell
playing Easy E Straight Out of comp now
who the [__] is going to say he
shouldn't have got
something um or maybe they did do that I
gotta be honest with you I don't I don't
really pay attention to award shows I
[__] can't stand
them
um they're horrific they're [__]
horrific they're boring as hell there's
usually one moment that's worth [__]
watching and at that with the internet
you're not going to miss it they're just
going to show it to you so why would you
waste four
hours of your life watching this [__]
like for the Golden Globes the the the
moment of the night was Jim Carrey Jim
Carrey stole that even that [__]
speech was hilarious and from what I've
heard um from people out here he just
winged that thing that's how [__]
funny that guy is um and watching him do
that in the brutal honesty of it really
made me wish I could still watch him do
standup to be honest honest with you um
all right here we go to your health good
sir Bill I've heard you discuss many
topics with with yourself on the podcast
about Health and Longevity uh of the
major topics I.E food and exercise I
would have to suggest considering
another area to focus on
breathing oh Jesus I got to work on this
too breathing is huge how you breathe
and the types of breaths you take during
the day to really change your body for
the better I just literally thought
about breathing I got more relaxed this
is this yoga [__] that I try to slow my
brain down for conscious breathing
conscious breathing oh you going to plug
your book in the middle of this you
[__] you know what you you got
me you suckered me in but I'm going to
read it like Deep Thoughts by Jack Handy
here we go conscious breathing is a book
and a great place to
start also a man by the name of whm Hoff
is doing amazing things and has been on
Joe Rogan's
podcast you may not have 3 hours to
listen to it but if you run into Joe I'm
sure he can give you the
breakdown thanks for the free
laughs um no I'll listen to anybody
that's on Rogan's podcast Joe Rogan's
podcast the fastest [__] three hours
you're ever going to spend you ever ever
lucky enough to be a [__] guest you
going be like I've been here like 40
minutes and then all of a sudden you're
like how the [__] is it like 7:00 at
night like I I missed I missed my meal
um well I'll I'll give it a chance I'll
give it a try I know I I definitely need
to [__] stress less and uh that's
always like one of my goals I haven't
been drinking this year though the day
after the Rose Bowls the last time I I
boozed
um I had one gulp of wine after I made
this really rich dinner in my stomach I
needed to settle it so my wife was
drinking some wine I just took a gulp of
that and then the last three nights in a
row I'm getting rid of these Rose Bowl
beers I just drink like one light beer I
just have one and then then I'm done and
it just kind of makes me sleepy but I'm
I'm just trying to free up some room in
the fridge cuz every year at the end of
the Rose Bowl I get stuck with all the
extra beers and like [__] 15 cans of
half-used
mustard um I get all the condiments in a
broken cooler all right trash in the
ocean hey Bill I know you talk about
this all the time on your podcast but
believe it or not there are people who
do not believe our
trash uh being dumped in the ocean is a
problem well there's always going to be
those people there's also people that
thought the [__] world was flat well
I guess I would have thought the world
was flat if I lived back then people
didn't think that we were we're having
an effect on the
climate you know all the [__] trees
that we've cut down that alone you know
what I mean it's um all right anyways he
says there was another scientific study
done if you believe in that kind of
thing that states Plastics will outweigh
fish in the ocean by 2050 yeah I saw
that I don't think that that's going to
happen because I have a feeling that
Mother Nature has had enough with us and
we'll you know when they keep predicting
by
2090 the population will more than
[__] quintuple I think that you know
we're already long past the Tipping
Point scientists have said we're past
the point where we can even fixed this
[__] thing so I this is like when you
can't do your homework at some point
you're like
M and she comes down and helps you out I
think Mother Nature is going to do
that and uh she's an old school mom and
she's going to slap the [__] out of
us um but you don't need to listen to me
say this just listen to George Carlin
he'll tell you all about it um all right
he said I guess these [__] assume
they'll be dead by then and don't give a
[__] longtime listener here just saw you
in Indie back in October I can assure
you we aren't all ignorant KKK [__]
or Jim ersay fans you know you know I
just say that just to [__] with you
Jesus Christ I grew up outside of
Boston half the people in the clan would
go there and be like all right hey take
it easy you know easy I understand but
easy all right thanks and go [__]
yourself and then they sent me the uh
the unbelievably
depressing link which I don't I don't
even go to him anymore I don't even go
to him anymore cuz all they do is
depressed me all right average amount of
waste produced by humans Jesus Christ
we're just staring into this hey
Bill I'm from Colombia and love your
podcast and your standup comedy hey
that's [__] great oh you're from
Columbia I thought you were down there
listening um but whatever you're from
there right you live there at some point
you still listening to the podcast it's
still cool uh he goes um the or she goes
I don't know who the [__] wrote this he
goes the other day I was wondering ing
how much poop is produced by humans on a
daily basis and I did a little research
on the internet and some calculations
which I would like to share with you and
your
audience okay according to the World
Factbook the world population
consists of 7
b174
611 wait a minute one what 7 b174 mil
people and the average human being
weighs around
62 kilog oh you [__] I I want to
know what that is in pounds I I I got to
I got to switch that over I want to see
where the [__] I'm
at wait what did you just say
62 what do you guys think the average
person I say the average person weighs
about a lot of starving people I I'll go
pounds what what do he say here all
right
in
lbs all
right that's equal to 136 pounds holy
[__] God damn it there's a lot of small
or starving people in the
world all right now the average that
means I am right now I'm like 40 pounds
over the average and the average human
being all right now the daily average
for stool gross is 1 o
per 12 lb of body weight which means the
average person poops
11.39% water dude this is
gross it would be safe to say that human
produce 1,
72197 metric tons of poop every
day Jesus Christ you're really taking
all the fun out of this
podcast to put this in perspective I
think you put it into perspective but
he's going to keep going the Empire
State Building weighs
350,000
tons so human beings pup the equivalent
of five giant turds the size of the
Empire State Building if we add farts to
the equation this [__] dude is all
in the average person farts 17 times a
day that's it try eating a salad [__]
double your numbers you break Dan
Marino's record times 17 times a day
producing a litter a liter of fart in
total a litter l i t t e r that's a
litter of fart in total which gives a
new meaning to a breathing fresh
air
I have included the links where I got
the
information at the end of this email and
when you think about it on top of eating
our own rollerblades we're eating our
own [__] by the way everything you read
or hear about Colombia is true go have a
meaningful experience with
yourself does that mean go oh that means
go [__] yourself ah this guy's a clever
son of a
[__]
um Jesus Christ well you know
hey how about I end the podcast with
what I promised to do last week which is
I was going to start reading segments
from the Bible now granted I don't own a
Bible all right let's start with John
3:16 because I'm a sports
fan John
3:16 he sth unto you
with all right John 3:16 for God so
loved the world that he gave his only
his one and only son that whoever
believes in him shall not perish perish
but have eternal life well that's
straightforward he let his kid die so as
long as you believe that that happened
you will not die you will have eternal
life you will live forever think about
that
forever you know you ever been at the
DMV just imagine that except it never
ends right
what the [__] would you do
forever there's no way that that's
[__]
true you know movies don't go on forever
planets don't go on forever or livable
planets don't go on forever oh [__] this
this is why I don't read the Bible I
just don't I don't [__] get all right
let's let's let's uh let's just look up
Bible passages b i e it'd be funny if
this actually got me back to going to
church I still love going to church you
know what I mean I still like going you
know keep in mind that Jesus Christ has
died for us and is
risen from the dead all right
encouraging Bible verses Hope bible
verses Bible verses by friendships Bible
verses let's give
hope encouraging well where the fck [__]
is
it ah I just want to open it like the
phone
book The Bible I'm going look up the
Bible please read the
Bible www a free Bible on your phone I
don't want it I want it on my [__]
screen I want a Hamburg Noah
cheeseburg official Kim James
Bible commit thy way unto the Lord trust
also in him and he shall bring it it to
pass bring
what commit thy way unto the Lord all
right so walk in the general direction
of the Lord trust also in him well if
I'm walking towards him aren't I isn't
that trusting him what do you think I'm
creeping up on him hey man just making
sure everything's cool I'm walking your
way but you know just wave your white
flag don't open a trap door when I get
there dude and he shall bring it to
pass Genesis oh I remember reading
this it like makes sense for like three
[__] sentences and then you're just
like what in the beginning God created
the Heaven and the
Earth and the Earth was without form and
void and darkness was upon the face of
the deep period the Deep what and the
spirit of God moved upon that's like
when they go you know they got to eat up
some
clock Darkness was upon the the face of
the deep and the spirit of God
moved upon the face of the
waters I thought there wasn't
any thought there wasn't any water there
wasn't anything how was there water for
his face to be on and God said let there
be light and there was light let there
be sound there was sound is this Bon
Scott God said let there be light and
there was light well what was he doing
before that he was just sitting in the
darkness all by himself
just one day he's laying there going I'm
going to make some [__] and God saw the
light that it was good and God divided
the light from the
darkness God called the light this like
Cam Newton everything's about the same
guy I'll tell you right now nobody's
having more fun than God making Earth
he's like a kid in a candy store that
doesn't exist and kids don't exist cuz
he haven't made it
yet ah [__] this
Genesis let's look up
job let's see what old job had to say
where the [__] is
he oh let's read Titus that's the name
of a comic I know how about that all
right Paul a servant of God and an
apostle of Jesus
Christ according to the faith of God's
elect and the acknowledging of the truth
which is after
godliness I feel like somebody's trying
to sell me a car that was all one
sentence in Hope of eternal life which
God that cannot lie promised before the
world
began dude this is like like God called
everything you know before you even born
and all but hath in due times manifested
his word you know what I thought this
would be a funny bit this is just
[__] annoying but hath in due times
manifested his word through preaching
which is committed unto me according to
the Commandment of God our savior it
just it just goes in circles to Titus my
own son after the common Faith he had
another kid he had Jesus then he had
Titus grace mercy and
peace who were they was Grace Grace was
she another virgin how many times is he
going to use this virgin think he banged
him right he had Jesus with Mary and
then Grace was his [__] side piece
and he had Titus
right for this cause left I Thee in cre
that thou should us set in order the
things that are wanting and orders
Elders in every city as I appointed thee
if any be blameless the husband of one
wife having faithful children not
accused of Riot or
unruly it's not a sentence well maybe it
was back then you know
what if I get judged someday you know
and and God standing there and being
like I just be like dude I you know I
tried to get through I tried to get
through the book I I don't know what to
tell
you as far as I can it's a bunch of
fragments all
right they're not complete thoughts you
know you can't write just because you
put a period at the end of it doesn't
make it a
sentence
right all right that's the podcast for
this week once again
congratulations to the Broncos
congratulations to the lady who got a
job I'm going to end this positive
congratulations to the lady who got the
job there with the Buffalo Bills I'm
sure you're going to do a great job I'm
just a grumpy old [__] man who team
lost all right congratulations to the
Panthers um I look forward to seeing Cam
Newton you know play against pton
Manning it's going to be great I love
that he called him the
sheriff um I thought that was cool you
know the best of the old versus the best
of the new so I'm an old [__] so I'm
going to have to root I got to root for
uh the Denver Broncos the AFC and pton
Manning um even though I love the
Panthers and I love the way they [__]
playing their defense is the [__] and um
I don't know I just hope it's a good
game I hope the Panthers if they're
going to win or the Broncos I just don't
want anybody beating the [__] out of
anybody right but I will tell you as
always I will be watching it by myself
okay I'm not going to I might go to a
Super Bowl party because my team's out
it but I I don't think so I want to see
Payton's last game and I hope he goes
out like laway and uh I'm going to do
what I always
do all right I'm going to tape the game
you let it go for a good 90
minutes as I mentioned you shut your
phone off you get the grill going you
crack a couple of beers you know you
make yourself a burger or two you invite
a couple of friends over and then you go
all right let's sit down and watch it
and you blow through all the [__]
beginning and the home of the brave
right boom kick off there we go blow
through all the [__] commercials fast
forward through Beyonce lips syncing
during halftime you'll get caught up
halfway way through the third [__]
quarter and uh and if there were any
cool commercials that you missed you
have them recorded but someone's going
to put them up online anyways you're not
going to miss a [__] thing and you
can to watch the Super Bowl in about I
don't know you can watch it in about two
two hours and 20 minutes two hour two
and a half hours it's [__] tremendous
all right God bless you guys yet go [__]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday all
right
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast show NFL
Edition for
championship week we are down to the
final four I'm happy to be back I know
some of you missed me I feel better this
week I'm not [__] my brains out and
throwing up all over the place so still
didn't miss a show still did not miss
the show he had food poison and he still
brought himself onto the stage old
school took a lot it took a lot but I
did it um but I went two and two last
week I don't know what did I I didn't
know anything about you guys because I
was we picked the exact opposite games
and we both went two and two okay we
went head-to-head like everything that I
said it's like Paul's going the other
way Paul's going the other way and I was
saying I want a 4-0 and an 0 and four I
don't want two and two and that's
exactly what we got we both got two and
two I mean those people in Buffalo if
they have to deal with another wide
right oh you know what [__] them I'm so
sick of everybody acted like they oh my
God it's got to be so [__] hard Paul
nobody chance anything at them nobody
what do you mean the [__] Rangers my
whole time growing up 1940 just rubbing
it in your face in some regular season
[__] game they chanted 1918 at the
[__] Red Sox dude look at the Lions
the Lions went 0 and 16 haven't sniffed
a [__] Championship since the
1950s and I gota be honest with you too
Paul okay I just want to say this okay I
have empathy for him and everything like
that but this whole [__] thing is it
the worst thing ever to be a Buffalo
Bills fan nobody is giving them [__]
yeah so they should scream are you
saying that they should start chanting
wide right when they're on the
road I mean it's you would think they
would but they
don't they I do you know what it is Paul
I feel bad for him when I saw that man
in the crowd who was like look he was in
his late 20s early 30s just he broke
down crying oh dude I know I mean that
was [__] pathetic Paul the [__] that
I saw as a [__] Red Sox fan as a
Patriots fan as a Bruins fan growing up
yeah you didn't break down and cry now
listen we were walled off emotionally
but there has been an overcorrection in
the the American male the fact that that
guy could start pulling his hat down and
openly sobbing in public with a pom pom
hat on is just like that that's I mean
that's the kind of thing that gets your
country invaded I'm I'm just
saying I I don't I will never understand
although I I did cry one time in 1994
when we lost game seven to the Houston
Rockets but I was drunk and I was a kid
you know so it's like and you were like
16 I was hammered I was like 15 or 16
you know it was a great Nicks run and I
was just I didn't cry I was like but I
was like [__] dicks like [__] like
that you got emotional you got emotional
but that guy you're right Cry game six I
didn't cry all the [__] Patriots
losses I didn't cry couldn't beat the
[__] goddamn Canadians forever
anytime we went in that [__] building
they'd always put on a power play it was
[__] annoying I didn't cry cry dude
the guy was
like what the [__] pull it together oh
pull it together that what are you going
to do when when when you when there's a
[__] flood the last time I saw crying
like that was when we saw that guy from
Argentina in the World Cup that's the
thing that's the thing give you a little
better I'll give you a little leeway
I'll give you a little leash with the
World Cup it's every four years your
country might have never NFL you're
coming back next year what do you break
it down for with parody
relax it was it was it was a bad look
and I also I forgive an athlete for
crying that's your dream you were that
close I get it I get that I don't have a
[__] problem with an athlete but if
you're in the [__] stands Paul just
some regular guy putting his sweatpants
on one [__] oversized leg after
another I don't want to watch you
[__] and I don't judge Buffalo Bill
fans off of that one [__] guy I don't
you no you know what I bill you know
what I just thought of how funny would
it be if they got beaten down with wide
right chance so much that every time a
buffalo guy missed it always just went
hard left because he
overcompensated dude I went to that
Buffalo Bills game I had a Patriots hat
on and that dude waited till I had my
dick out pissing and he pushed me from
behind [__] all this because you lost
all of a sudden your salt of the earth
people they're just as big a [__] as
anybody you find in New York or uh real
or Massachusetts real New York or
Massachusetts because they don't live in
real New York all right they're
basically Canadian I wanted them to go
man I did I was rooting for him but but
here's the thing too that [__] wide
right is not the reason why they lost
that game they needed to bring their a
game and they didn't bring their a game
it's true they didn't convert and they
[__] how many drop passes did they have
how many times did Tony Romo go yeah
probably should have had that well how
about that bomb that absolute bomb I
can't remember the last time I saw a
ball that high and far and then Diggs it
went in through diggs's thing I mean
dude you catch that gotta catch that
catch that who catches that who catches
that Jerry Rice Randy M oh I said to
catches that I said you know who catches
that bomb and he goes I know Dad Randy M
you know how much I love
him uh yeah Jerry Rice Swan would have
caught it John stalworth would have
caught it yeah yeah Drew Pearson catches
that ball you got to catch that [__]
ball gotta catch that bomb and then
you're on the 10 another thing too even
if that kid made the field goal they did
they were gonna chiefs were GNA go right
down the [__] field and they were
gonna score like they did who's their
running back just runs like [__]
Roger Craig Isiah Pacho Man kids I mean
not isaah yeah peo great great knees
High [__] elbows just tearing through
their line he reminded me of Ahad
Bradshaw and the giants like that's
those little guys that just run hard and
run with the purpose um nothing he did
reminded me of the Giants running game
but continue no well you don't know I'm
my Bradshaw man that was the guy um when
uh 200 like six to
2009 um but we lost to Super Bowl to you
then I don't remember that guy uh number
44 I remember your defense I remember
Eli Manning yeah I wasn't thinking oh
God not not [__] Ahad Brad Bradshaw I
sawad Bradshaw at at that party Willis
whan hooked us up with and I walked up
to him he was just sitting I go dude you
ran so hard for us thanks so much and he
was just so he was like I was like you
know you know me I love the athletes but
you make a good point
Bill white leather and
athletes you uh you make a good point
Bill the Kansas City chief scored on the
first seven drives of the [__] game
Where's the defense where's the defense
first seven dve the bills the bills are
still not ready for prime time they had
no business winning that [__] game
the way that they played and they're
gonna blame their stupid [__] kicker
sass right B and he's going to walk
around laces out for the rest of his
[__] life and everybody's going to
forget all those Dro passes they're
going to forget how they just [__]
went right down the field and scored on
them yeah get a stop all right you
missed the field goal get a stop three
and out get a [__] stop they went
right down the field Paul like butter on
Thanksgiving giving the kid death
threats what the [__] are you doing
threatening a kid's life assuming you're
gonna win the coin toss assuming punch
your dad like you really want to yeah so
and then he makes the kick you assume
you're gonna get the coin toss you
assume you're gonna get the ball get a
touchdown and win totally disregarding
everything that Kans City Chiefs could
do you it's it's a it's a rough was a
rough one you know yeah they scored like
70 points the last time they went the
playoffs with the the the Chiefs and
they still lost like
7170 yep
yep yeah know I'm not I'm not doing
this I'm not doing I'm not gonna [__]
glorify a fan base because they don't
[__] win those guys are just as big a
[__] is any other fan base all right
pushing a man in his back when he has
his dick out I mean come on Paul I mean
where where oh it got any other bills
fan going hey hey well let him finish
pissing first and I was like in my 40s I
was an old [__] man taking a whiz
trying to hope the [__] Ur went by my
swollen prostate and this guy pushes me
in the back like he plays for the
[__] Penguins you were in a
vulnerable position man and he took
advantage of it he took advantage of a
vulnerable position you don't touch a
man with his dicks in his hand you just
don't you just
don't and you know what's [__] up you
shouldn't have to tell people that but
evidently you have to tell the people of
Buffalo that dude if a mob guy came to
put a hit on you and kill you he would
be like all right zipo finish
up finish up go ahead finish you hungry
you want something to
drink all right uh the the other game
the other game was a weird one because
the Texans are in the game at Halftime
1010 I'm going oh [__] and then boom
buff Baltimore happened that's the one
that I lost you won that one you call
that one yeah I thought basically I
thought the Texans and Green Bay had
their game last uh two weeks ago in the
super far out [__] keep on trucking
Wild Card Weekend that the NFL had
weekend yeah super duper super duper
fragilistic [__] Wild Card
Weekend yeah I mean there's enough
people that's like [__] the nhls like
half the [__] League was playing that
weekend not the Patriots but they were
right and uh I thought that that was
okay that was they had great games
against teams that can't win Wild Card
Weekend they're going to turn into
pumpkins and I just thought the uh
Texans were young and I thought Green
Bay was the same thing and I I believe
sort of in the 49ers 49ers man they're a
weird team dude they kind of crowned
Brock py like he's this [__] grizzled
vet and as far as I hear with that guy
all they're doing is just like yeah he's
[__] he throws the ball before the
guy even makes the cut we've already
talked about that that's how you play
quarterback you have to do that at the
college level or to get a knockdown
um unless you play for Yale yeah going
going back to the Texans that's a great
year for them rookie quarterback
inexperienced coach they get to that
round they get to the divisional round
it's a great year for the Texans but
you're not going to beat an experienced
Baltimore team with John Harbaugh and
Jackson I just like the points I like
the nine and a half but they [__] put
it on them um I guess we'll make some
picks Bill we are in we are in
Championship weekend we have the Detroit
Lions and the 49 and we have the Ravens
and the the Chiefs in Baltimore what
what are the spreads here let's go
Andrew what are the what are the current
bet MGM lines
here three and a
half three and a half I'll tell you this
right now Paul I the Chiefs getting
points in the [__] playoffs I believe
in the Chiefs I believe in Patrick
Mahomes I believe in Andy Reid until
somebody shows me that I shouldn't those
[__] guys don't let passes go through
their hands those guys you know when
they do that Paul they do it in November
when it doesn't [__] matter but come
January these guys just get [__]
locked
in um yeah yeah but I'll tell you one
I'm not saying they're gonna win the
[__] game but they're gonna cover
three and a half I I think the Ravens
defense at home I think Ravens are
different at home I think it's going to
be a monster game the three and a half
is perfect it's so perfect I hate the
point five I hate the if it's three I
take the Ravens if it's three and a half
I got the
Chiefs I didn't think it's going to be a
close game and someone's going to go
into the prevent little [__] garbage
time back door cover that's how I see it
Paul I agree with you 100% I think the
Ravens are GNA win the game by three or
two yeah uh you know what be cool dude
like this has never happened two
brothers winning the in the same year
winning the uh college football
championship and then the Super Bowl
that would be amazing that would be
amazing but I think Lamar Jackson's G to
be a lot for um the one thing that you
learned about the that's the thing I
didn't like about their offense who when
I was watching the Ravens as much as
they put it on the Texans so much of it
was him dropping back and then taking
off and running yeah now I don't know
the Chiefs don't don't exactly have they
don't defense they don't have a great
defense I don't know I just get like
that's like college football like Tim
TBO level offense you know I drop back I
look nobody's open and then I run for
[__] eight
yards yeah but the one thing that is
about the the that they were saying
about the Chiefs and I saw it you could
see it with Buffalo is the Chiefs don't
have a good run defense and I think
running the I don't think the Chiefs
have had a good [__] defense during
this whole time that they've been the
top dog in the AFC they' never had a
lights out [__] defense no defense is
okay but the the no run defense I like
um I like Baltimore to win the game
Tyreek Hill they had Kelce they had
[__] Patrick
Mahomes like they had all of that [__]
going on and they were offense heavy you
just ch I'm I just changed my mind I
just changed my own mind do that Paul
you [__] you've been killing at this
[__] don't listen to me I'm win some
lose some Billy no no no I'm going
against
you I I'm say okay good I like that I
like Baltimore to win the game by I
think Baltimore is going to win the game
by by they should win the game by a
touchdown I'm being scared
I'm being scared because it's Mahomes
can't lose [__] that dude Baltimore's
better they got a better defense they
home I'm taking the Ravens and you know
what I heard in that they should win
that game not they will they should win
that game and that's what [__]
happens when people play the Chiefs on
paper you should [__] beat them in
the playoffs and then you
don't well Twinkle Toes throws a
[__] dude the guy floats around he's
got to dance back ground you know does a
little soft shoe back
there I'm expecting him after three
throws to just do a Michael
Jackson
uh uh yeah the whole thing the way he
walks the way he runs the way he throws
it's just not it's not uh it's not the
marble man back there you saw that kid
on Instagram do an impression of him oh
dude it was you know my two favorite was
that one and then the guy doing joic is
it joic or yic I'm not an NBA guy the
guy in Denver oh yo it's it's joic yeah
yeah because they call him Joker so I
always end up [__] it up yic when he
was doing like the kind
of just throwing it up like that and he
had
his it's like his head neck and
shoulders are all like fused like just
he just when he walks it's just kind of
like have you ever goodes out there have
you ever seen an NBA superstar Champion
give a [__] less about his job no you
know what the big shame is Jason law had
never [__] uploaded his batting
stances I saw some guy doing Reggie
Jackson the other day I just it
disgusted me compared to Jay laads I
don't know why the [__] he never put
those things up those would have went
viral they were
unbelievable yeah they were un [__]
believe people used to come walking over
from the other
tailgates to watch like he [__] doing
Ricky Henderson yeah was
great uh all right so Bill's got the
Chiefs I got the Ravens moving on to the
next game Bill I've been thinking about
this game I've been driving in the car
I've been thinking about this game and
it hit me I'm gonna go as far as to say
for me this is a no-brainer and I know
that could be the kiss of death I
absolutely with all the thinking that
I've done with this love love the
Detroit Lions I think the Detroit Lions
are going there with house money that
the casino gave them they they all the
pressure is on the 49ers I think that
the lions got a great quarterback I
think they got a good defense they got a
coach they'll run through a wall for and
they are this close and I love the seven
points I think it's I think they could
be in that game and I gotta be honest
with you I didn't love how the 49ers
played against the Packers man if that
kid on the Packers doesn't throw across
his body they have a chance to go down
there and win the game with one drive at
the end of the game and Debo Samuel I
believe this Jake The Snake can pop in
here for our injury report I believe
Debo Samuel is 50% to play and did not
look at Jake The Snake right now you
telling me he doesn't look like Hugh
Jackman getting ready to play wolverine
look at this kid what's going on Jak
ladies he's single get get after
him um yeah that that's the one big
injury from this whole weekend is um
Debo up in the air with a concussion um
but yeah other than that everyone else
is going to play but um yeah that's a
that's a big one for sure he's a
fantastic player I think the Lions going
there Lucy goosey and they got an
opportunity to take out the big dog at
the end of the game I love the seven
points your boy Paulie's taking the
Lions Bill what do you
got um somebody brought up an
interesting point about the 49ers they
were saying how they don't play well
from behind they haven't had to do that
uh which kind of goes into my theory
that Brock Pie as well as he's playing
he's driving a [__] Lamborghini and
it's kind of like just keep it on the
road um
I kind of feel like they had their
stinkeroo last week I can see uh
Christian mcaffrey and just coming out
going up in the beginning and I think it
stays close for about a quarter and a
half and then they start pulling away
and they start going like you know with
these lines they don't need to hang
their heads you know this is something
they can build on Dan Campbell has them
believing that they're gonna [__] I
just see it going that way seven points
I do not
like I do not like them Sam I am uh [__]
that's such
a once again if it's six 49ers all
day
um you know what I think the first one's
going to be close I think 49 I think uh
Ravens and and uh the Chiefs will be a
close one and uh but I think the 49ers I
don't think this is going to be close I
think they're gonna pull away in the
second half and uh they're gonna it's
gonna be you know it's going to be uh
49ers versus
Chiefs that's what I see I do think the
49ers go to the Super Bowl but I can see
the Lions covering in the back door
cover so I'm G to take the lions with
the points and I'm G to take the Ravens
what do you think about the conspiracy
theory that whatever colors they use I
love that conspiracy theory that
whatever the three years too I love that
I love it's so funny like it's like if
you're fixing games what is it do is it
because you want get caught like why
would you do
that oh did you see Rashad Jennings the
ex- running back he was watching he goes
he goes guys guys he goes can you just
tell me why he goes why would Tampa Bay
not call a timeout here he goes this is
the [__] that makes people think it's
fixed and he looks at the camera he goes
which it's absolutely not yeah uh what
it is is you watch like [__] that
doesn't make sense and then you watch
human behavior yeah of them like [__]
I think though it's saged through rule
changes to give you know they've
definitely like the level of advantage
that the offens have had for the last 20
years in order to grow the sport because
they know that offense gets the Casual
fan it's the problem with soccer there's
just not enough goals for an American
okay we like portions we like big
[__] portions and if they changed
that
game either they had a little person in
the net or they made the goal bigger I
think Americans would start watching if
the games were like seven to
five right I agree at what point did you
tune out during that Paul Jesus Christ I
felt like I was just [__] no I was
talk I'm taking like a job fair no I'm
taking it in I've uh done some wait
waiting tables and I've I where I worked
on the line too okay well we'll find
find a place for you no no no no I was I
was I was no I was taking it in I think
that there's two typ of people that
watch a game I think there's people that
watch football who cry and people who
don't or like people like when me and
you watched when me and you watched that
Monday night game uh at your house and
we sat down and we enjoyed the Bengals
and whatever me and you were watching it
different than a [__] guy going like
the [__] he doing look at this [__]
like I got friends that do that look at
this [__] guy this guy can't and
you're like you're not it's like no dude
that ball Watchers yeah it's like that
happened because the quarterback had two
seconds cuz the defensive line is
bullying the offensive line like that n
[__]
that he doesn't want to be out there you
know he got a big contract yeah yeah the
coach doesn't discipline him that's what
like those guys that call up the radio
station I watched a fight on I watched a
fight on UFC the other night and it was
these two it was a it was a co-main
event and it was this two uh uh female
female UFC fighters going for the uh the
what is it the the [__] what was
Ronda Rousey bantamweight bantamweight
Championship uhuh and they said that the
one chick who needed to win needed to do
a certain style in order to beat this
Brazilian and she had to make an
adjustment in the fight which made the
fight not as action packed but made her
super smart and control the time and
control things and people are going oh
my God this woman's fight is the most
boring I thought it was great I actually
thought it was great and in the
interview she goes yeah she goes that
fight didn't go how I planned it but I
needed to do this and I loved it all
that was online was people going oh my
God this [__] woman's fighted this
might be the worst fight I ever seen I
actually thought it was cool how she
made the adjustment to win the title so
because you appreciate the art of
fighting Paul I appreciate all of it
offense and defense you know Paul you're
a very appreciative person I like it all
if it's good man if it's good you know
hey I got one for you I apologize people
my I'm a [__] little sick here
um I got one you got to go back watch
Paul yeah with your whole [__]
Mayweather would have beat Haggler
Hearns Duran Leonard here's a fight you
have to [__] see okay yeah he would
have gone four and0 no he would have G
four and0 just walked right through that
[__] division even though all of them
took losses that's what you said you're
forgetting one but you're forgetting one
part of that argument in the Steak House
peekaboo [__] thing you wouldn't be
able to deal no laad and bartnik got me
going going they beat the [__] out of
that little [__] that's what got me
going they would [__] get him in the
so you match that lack of respect with
your own lack of respect I I didn't like
the guy that's undefeated and has good
defense being thrown in the corner and
beating the [__] out of like he wasn't a
champion that's made me go but go ahead
yeah that that that was that was too
disrespect you were the fairest one I
could say this you were the fairest one
at that table because you look at my
complexion I've always been the fairest
of all even though that's
when hey Bill you're always the fairest
always the fairest bill oh that was when
you said get this kid a Mal three months
out of the year I'm the reddest bartnik
loved when you said get this kid a malt
but you you go you go all right man I'll
give him two and two you know I'll give
him two and two all I was saying I
didn't even go three in one I mean but
there's no [__] way you're fighting
all of those guy like the like dude
Marvin Hagler went Marvin Haggler went
to a Floyd Mayweather junr event like
all memorabilia walked up to him and he
goes dude I'm such a huge fan would you
sign this you're like incredible like
Marvin Haggler did that so it's not like
you guys not you but somebody's like
they take that [__] little [__]
throw him in the car they would beat the
[__] out listen listen I never said that
and it's also like you started it saying
it though you started with he would beat
all of those guys did I say he would or
he could no to you is no question and
then secondly Marvin Haggler going up to
Mayweather and saying
that you have to understand who Marvin
Haggler is all right they [__] Marvin
Haggler on that Leonard fight they
[__] him on that on that thing like
you have to beat the champion all right
he Ray Leonard did not beat the champion
right okay that was like if you want
like the best I'll give you is that was
a draw okay I won't say that Haggler
beat Leonard but you have to beat the
[__] Champ to take the belt they
didn't so what they were doing was they
were [__] Marvin Haggler because they
figured he'd be so mad he would
immediately sign up for a rematch
because they were getting up there in
age and it's like we want to get paid
twice and blah blah blah blah blah and
[__] this guy's record and all of that
[__] so they [__] him but this is what
they didn't realize about him is Haggler
didn't give a [__] and he didn't give a
[__] about money and he just retired
said [__] it I'm out of here right so
for years after that Ray Leonard tried
to get a rematch with him and he was in
Italy you know making movies and [__]
doing all of that which is the funniest
conspiracy theory ever bartnik thinks
that Haggler threw the fight
so he could do [__] movies in Italy
that's how the mob paid him back that
the funniest [__] ever
um can you imagine that you're gonna
throw this fight wait I'm gonna lose to
Leonard yeah but you're gonna be a movie
star in Italy yeah but if I beat Leonard
then I beat all four of them and I'm one
of the greatest of all [__] time if
not the greatest if I do that no no
you're G to throw this fight but here's
here's the back you're G to do Marvin
Haggler The Good the Bad and the Ugly oh
okay right anyway years later Hagler
came back to the States he's at some big
event and lender was there and he sent
one of his people over there and said
hey man you know whatever you want let's
let's have another fight we can make a
zillion dollars blah blah blah the
pay-per-view would be sick and Haggler
said to that kid he goes tell I tell Ray
Leonard I said get a life and that's the
thing what it was about him was he was
done no but he was also at peace he's
also like he's one of those guys where
talent doesn't scare him so he can walk
up to Floyd and ask for his [__]
autograph you think Floyd would ask for
hagler's autograph
no no I don't know but I'm just saying
that is
like you know what I mean Paul you've
worked with [__] like Headliners
right coming up there's some that just
say a good job some that ignore you when
you're killed and there's other ones
going like God damn man you're really
funny what's your name here's my phone
number you need any help I'll help you
out there's those guys Haggler was that
guy a fight you got to watch
Paul and this guy doesn't even get
brought up you got to watch Marvin
Haggler versus John the Beast
mugabi oh is this what you were gonna
say before you said our argument thing
this is yeah okay that watch that fight
and know and watch the [__] shots
that mugabi throws and takes and know
that that division was so [__]
competitive people don't even bring
him's name
up yeah it's Haggler Hearns Duran
uh Leonard there's just there's not
enough
room MC it's like
Testament Testament they bring up the
big four and they leave Testament off
the [__] list and if they can totally
hang with them it's just not for some
reason it's Mount Rushmore right Mount
Rushmore has four guys on it four yeah
when I get reelected there will be five
I think that my head some people are
saying that my head should be above all
the other heads I I I don't know I don't
know it's my favorite thing ever I don't
know um
they should put John McCain's head up
there so he looks at it he be like who's
that it's like that's you
sir oh Paul Paul how much are you not
gon to watch politics this year I I
cannot I'm not gonna sit here and watch
this [__] show I think this is the end
this is like a
Trilogy all right this is [__] this
is when [__] Skywalker inv Vader
finally [__] no this is the this is
the rubber match 2016 2020 and
this is the rubber
match uh love what I [__] love was
liberals were so [__]
excited when he got booted out I was
excited too he's just such a hateful
racist [__] guy and giving like a
voice to these [__] racist morons
right it's just horrible to just see
somebody like that right um so I was
happy when he lost I had no idea that he
could run again and not only run again
Paul he could win this and then we have
eight more years of him so then if it
comes like Lial we should have just
taken our medicine and we would have
been done with
them no you can't get eight more you
could only do you can only do two terms
total no but you can come back and then
you can you can go back to back but I I
I maybe I read it wrong no no no you can
only since he's since he was four years
go he can't he can't go eight no what
you're thinking of is there was I was
hoping he going to go eight oh my God
Hollywood would have been the best place
ever to live huh was it Roosevelt that
did that did ended up with the extra
term I'm blanking I know he went three
years in a row because we were coming
out of the depression and then we were
in World War II right I thought there
was one that went four four space and
then two because they hadn't said well
it was consecutive and then they changed
it so then you're only allowed if you
were I thought it was like refinancing
your mortgage where you went back to
payment one you're like hey my payment's
lower it's like yeah the [__]
interest is through the goddamn roof
bill you want to know why I'm going to
watch no politics during this because my
New York make no mistake about I'm gonna
say it now I'm gonna say it now and I
mean it I mean it I don't doubt every
year when you say this the New York
Knicks are now probably the fifth best
team in the NBA and they are going to
make one more move by the deadline to
get a shooter Off the Bench and we are
back dude we are back we
have back from
what back from being the laughing stock
in the NBA but what are you back to
relevance competitiv all right well then
e we're we're back to what compe back to
being competitive all right I just
wanted you I want to say you you're
talking to a guy whose team has 17
[__] championships don't sit there
and talk to me like that don't
disrespect me like that okay no I'm not
going at you I'm not going like
anybody's nervous about the [__]
Knicks that's what that's the thing
though right now you don't want to play
the Knicks in the
playoffs yes we do no well now now you
might but you you just said right now
you don't want to play the Knicks in the
playoffs I said yes we do and you said
no you don't then you go well not now no
I'm saying by by May when the playoffs
come you're going to let me tell you
something Paul you know what's gonna
happen in the [__] playoffs you're
gonna go down there dressed like [__]
Lee with all your [__] wear you know
your [__] Nick Medallion and all of
that [__] you guys are going to jump up
and down don't you wish you were playing
for the Knicks and you guys are just
going to fade away like you always do
you know I'm not going to be down there
dressed I'm going to be sitting in front
of my TV with my son biting my nails
yelling at Stacy not to bother me for
three hours
fair
enough fair enough I don't hate the
Knicks either I just I just I the fact
that they are still
considered just so relevant and so
important to the NBA while doing nothing
but
losing it's just [__] ridiculous to
me that that your your your the Madison
Square Garden is still it's a Mecca all
a Mecca means is it's a place where
people go to
gather it doesn't mean like it's oh my
God I can't argue man until they win
until they win I get people saying I
don't want to hear it because I mamed
Ali Joe Frasier made that Arena famous
Frank Sinatra makes that Arena famous
well you're also forgetting oh no we got
to do this this Sunday night uh parlay
well don't forget though you know Clyde
Frasier and Earl The Pearl Monroe in the
70s was a something you know I mean I
it's a long time ago
but I'm just saying you know Paul can I
ask you a question you remember the 90s
when the Houston Rockets went back to
back is anybody calling their [__]
Stadium a [__] Mecca
no and that was only 30 years
ago I love how you thought about arguing
with that then you just laughed no
that's the thing that's that's what
sucks is like you can't because I do it
to Met fans until it happens you just
gotta wait uh it was it was
50 [__] years ago 1973 was 51 years
ago Dude wow yeah Paul look at you look
how you look look in the mirror look at
you good dude uhhuh yeah how do you what
do you think you look
like huh just know that in your entire
time okay as a as a person yeah you've
been able to get to the point where you
know you lost your
hair you got some white whiskers you're
growing a beard yeah had a Pontiac Paul
you drove a Pontiac SUV all of this [__]
happened and you know what didn't happen
during your entire existence on this
planet
Paul you slipped the disc
H you've been arrested you started
comedy had a couple kids you were an
open
micer you had a couple of cats that
lived for like 20 [__]
[Music]
years I did I did but you know what one
thing I also did though bill you saw OJ
when he back when he was a [__] hero
[__] movie star to go to a murderer
double murderer but get off on it all of
that stuff has happened Paul yeah jeans
were tight they got loose they they
became tight again and now they get
loose
again but I stayed loyal
Bill what but what hasn't happened Paul
that entire [__]
Time come on man you know are you doing
this to me you know well you know why
I'm doing this to you because your New
York arrogance we're gonna be back we're
going to be back you never
were you never were we were relevant in
90s like I mean actually we were you
know we went to the finals in the '90s
you were as relevant as the Pacers until
you played the
Pacers but we did go to the finals
against the uh Spurs in 99 with spr well
all right well you guys are the first
parti participation trophy NBA franchise
Paul Paul I'm just I'm just sick of of
of the [__] bravado and and all of
the [__] it's just you just don't
have the hardware Paul Paul for a guy
who loves jewelry Paul well here's likes
to walk around with his chain out I know
you know what Julie looks like here's
the deal you being sick of it is not
going to ever stop my love and passion
for my Knicks you understand I'm not
telling you to not have love and passion
I'm just saying just choose your words
carefully when you're talking to a
Celtics fan that's all it's respect like
what if I said right now you after 2018
when the Red Sox won there four and I
said this is our Century we're [__]
coming dude and you're sitting there
with 27
championships looking at me all excited
cuz we won four in the last 110 [__]
years right or 100 years you would be
looking at me like is this guy really
saying this [__] to me as a Yankees fan
is he really saying
that that's a good that's a good point
there you go so you had to get into your
[__] ego with the Yankees for you to
finally see it no no no I knew what you
were doing the whole time I saw it but
yeah you're right if a baseball team
talked to me about their couple of cute
titles and I see the almost 30 you're
right I would be like all right all
right here's my
question how long did the Yankees the
championship drought would it have to go
which is amazing that it's considered
like the fact that you guys have only
gone 15 years here and that's considered
like holy [__] yeah this is like your
second longest
drought I mean the longest one was 1980
1978 to 1996 that's how [__] spoiled
you are as Yankee
fans I would that was the that like dude
there's people just like you know the
Phillies win one like one every [__]
80 years or 40 40 years 80 years or
something to answer how long would it
have to go before people are like wow I
guess 32 teams all this jumping around
with money I guess you know George
steinbrener dying like this [__] is
actually
over I would say to answer that question
I would say if it got to like 25 years I
think if it went another decade from now
then people would start to have to be
like all right dude dude 25 years it's a
[__] quarter of a century without any
winning that would be a that would make
New York fans be like what the Yankee
fans go holy [__]
dude the it's over or could be over so
yeah I would say
25 it's not gonna go 25 I just don't
think I just you guys got you got too
much money you got a really good farm
team you guys were right there I don't
know what happened I I was too busy
watching the Red Sox we just
[__] just kept losing people to free
agency and getting nothing back from
everybody you know my about what's his
face who went to the Dodgers why we ever
let him go I don't know why I don't know
no [__] that though the Dodgers giv $700
million to one pitcher it's so stupid
I'm glad the Yankees didn't do that you
know it's like but the Yankees did do
that Paul you were the original 700
million to somebody just $700 million
wasn't $700 million 20 years ago right
but it's still now it's it's
to put somebody on your payroll for that
really [__] takes a big hit for your
farm oh it's beyond stupid it's beyond
stupid but I mean I can't listen to a
Yankee fan [__] sit here and say like
can you believe how much they paid that
guy I mean there was that time towards
the end of George Stein br's life like
there's nothing he loved more than a
38-year-old future Hall of Famer with
half a season left in him and give that
guy [__] 15 million yeah he did that
late he did that with the Oakland A's
right who did Stein brener when he got
uh who was the other than Reggie didn't
he get another Oakland A too Catfish
Hunter you got Reggie Jackson yeah um no
I I'm talking about like after the
2000s when he was going after like you
know Randy
Johnson uh what was it Kevin Brown what
was that guy's name yeah he got yeah he
got an old Randy Johnson he had Kevin
Brown he got uh who was the other guy
yeah we would get guys that were like
we' get a couple outfielders that kind
of zinski I think he gave him a 100
million have it past it [__]
Prime um he called Greg Linsky up who
had been retired for 15
years you play first base you don't have
to be that mobile he's like all right
just just eat up a few games for [__]
Tino yeah what was his name Tino
Martinez or Greg Greg
luzinski Greg luzinski yeah he was no
that's a guy from like the 70s and 80s
yeah yeah you look like a softball
ringer you know when you play somebody
else and it's just supposed to be people
you know one one Warehouse versus
another warehouse and then this guy
comes up with a [__] ass as big as a
Volkswagen Bug and you're like who the
[__] is this
guy um you know what we gotta go sends
one into the parking lot hits somebody's
Volkswagon Shaco that was the80s Paul
those fat out of shaped guys that just
would hit [__] oh it's the best it's
the best you guys had that [__] you know
that guy you guys had Moon oh my God
that guy dude that guy hit a home run at
sh stadium that I swear to God I can't
even believe a human being hit a ball
that far oh yeah he would hit the moon
shots and he would almost fall he would
[__] he would and he did like that that
way up there that [__] swing I loved
Moon oh moon hit [__] bombs
dude um you know what we got to do if
when the NBA so just go he made little
effort to field balls at first base who
are we talking about there mo mo Moon I
remember being on the first Baseline in
the Red Sox game you know kid in the
990s like we like Moon it was just that
was flavor of the week and man I just
was flavor of the week he was he was
there that he was he was there for our
team around him that guy was great in my
like 40 years of fandom but but but yeah
he was that for that that period he was
the biggest player but uh no I remember
literally just watching him like stumble
forward for a ball just terrible
Fielding didn't always try he could but
very rarely but yeah moon was one of the
one of those big guys I love I he was
great oh [__] Moon shots dude
moonshots I know that's back when we
didn't understand like hitting and
running and stealing bases and all that
we just used to sign one guy after
another like that we'd always like Dave
Kingman late in his career be like dude
he gets defway yeah with the green
monster that he's GNA hit like 80
[__] home runs you know what he would
do ground into double plays they would
just pitch those guys [__] low and
inside they would yeah turn on it that
was before Money Ball analytics guys
would just get Sluggers back then oh
yeah you know uh no that's what it was
all about uh that's why the national
league was more exciting because they
were playing a complete game like they
were playing hit and run they were doing
stealing bases they were doing all of
that [__] they had to you
know it just was a more fun game and I
love watching the pctures bat I hate
that they they they changed that that's
stupid um anyways Paul this is getting
late here and I gotta go [__] I gotta
get the writers from here um
um bringing in Big Boy Gian oh yeah yeah
gibi was another guy gii was a guy throw
him at first have him hopefully he
[__] hits [__] bombs and and
that's it um ran like he had [__] in his
pants licking his lips the whole way
down the lick licking his lips when he
would when he would try to steal a base
he was halfway there just
struggling and he put his head
up uh rest his rest his brother's Soul
uh his brother passed away horrible man
um horrible um Jeremy rest of Soul all
right so we'll do a part you about
Harbaugh going to the San Diego Chargers
I think Diego
superchargers I think it's great oh you
know Paulie's gonna be picking San Diego
next year I love Herbert and I think
he's got a quarterback a quarterback
coach type of Coach that's gonna make
him win I love it you know what was
awesome was reading all of these Ohio
State fans calling Harbaugh cheater
they're such [__] babies they are
such
[__] they had the biggest [__]
crybabies and they given the guy no
respect and secretly they're they're so
unbelievably excited that he's gone it's
like if all you Ohio State fans out
there he didn't even coach in the game
this year and you still get your [__]
ass kicked you are you are beyond happy
that that guy is leaving you'd be
psyched if he left Michigan and came to
you
guys yeah how great is it you leave your
omma Mater you go I mean you leave you
go back to your mat you win a
championship there you're like now I'm
going to go to the NFL I'm going to go
to one of the a good quarterback they
got a great team I think the Chargers
are going to be good let's do our last
pick let's do a pick let's do a parlay
here we have the um we could do either
one right
Andrew it's our it's our
world I guess it is he's not here
anymore uh he said yes he said yes okay
which game do you like better which game
do you like better for a special bill
you like the Ravens and Chiefs or do you
like the Lions and Niners
um I think they're both pretty good you
tease the [__] I you tease the the
49ers down if you or if you tease the L
somebody up and that uh
Chiefs how how much well I mean that
that'll affect your odds but like how
how much can you tease these guys up and
down you I think you could get you could
it's six or you could buy seven Andrew
can we do a tease I never noticed though
that uh it's on the bed MGM
yeah yeah we can we always we've done
that with the over under we've teased it
up or down so yeah I would
100% all right so this is what we'll do
we will do a championship week tease a
two- team tease we'll
take we'll tease the 49ers down you want
to tease the 49ers down to one point
well I think two I think two that'll two
out of three momes to throw one and then
tease them up to like almost 10
points is pretty good let's just go
49ers just go 49ers I I have no idea I
mean I have no idea on that Chiefs I
mean I think it's going to be close but
then part of me is going
like dude let's get the r n let's get
the Ravens getting nine and a
half all right you think I mean you
think the Ravens are gonna lose by 10 at
home and I got no feeling on that game
Paul I'm like [__] Maverick right now
it's no good yeah it's no good see
it dude that's the that's the best
analogy but no it's no good it's no good
no good come on MAV pull the trigger no
it's no good I got to go back to the
cruise ship take my shirt off and play
volleyball you know what I [__] hate
about all those movies that I enjoyed in
the 80s and then people go it was latent
homosexuality it's like yeah if you were
gay I just thought it was a bunch of
guys [__] playing volleyball I never
thought that they were blowing each
other after it that's on you right yes
yeah I'm like no dude these guys are in
good shape with plane is shaped like a
dick it's like is
it yeah dude if I had that body I'm no
shirt on the beach playing volleyball
hot out what I gonna do keep my shirt on
um all right it was an impromptu game of
volleyball you saw they had their jeans
on yeah they're not going to all start
sucking each other's dick when the
game's over yeah where does that come
from like Batman and Robin oh there a
really homosexual thing going on in
there was
there I thought Batman was trying to
[__] Catwoman dude please do this on
stage that is so funny God that's funny
it's like yeah are you sure maybe this
might be a u
issue yeah I think you're gay I think
you want to see these guys start
queering off with each other which is
fine but don't [__] tell me that that
was the purpose of that scene that's
scene was supposed to get women all
excited to go to the movie that's why
they had him oiled up they didn't do it
for me why is he crying to his best
friend about his wife maybe he wants to
suck his dick it's like wait or or it's
his friend or his friend
died dude that's the ultimate dude I
called it Maverick watch the canopy he
[__] called
It Go slammed right into it and died ohh
dude and he had come so far he couldn't
get any [__] in college he was in the
worst fraternity you know and then once
they got revenge on those [__]
athletes next thing you know he joins
the armed services he's flying jets oh
that's great that's great he's banging
Meg [__] Ryan I mean the guy's here
his whole life Maverick called it watch
the canopy
Goose bam that's like watch the fake
punt they call a fake punt that was
another thing the bills did that [__]
fake punt you know that was the
end him up oh no and they put Hamlin in
the middle dude it was predictable and
terrible good call good call um all
right we're gonna blame SAS you know
we're just gonna blame him
instead yeah Jake Jake The Snake just
said at your own 30 dude yeah that's a
that's a bad coaching
move I tell it's great if it works I was
Reckless I don't know what I was
thinking when I made that call Paul he
would have been a hero if it worked it's
like
uh all right so we'll do ravens getting
nine and a half no no no not 49ers minus
10 49ers minus 10 means they got to win
by 11 you don't want that don't you
think the 49ers Lo logo that minor with
the short shorts on there just a lot of
latent homosexuality going on
there you know he's bending over to pan
for gold dude did you see Lamar Lamar
Jackson's teammate go up to him on the
bench and rub his head after that great
play gu want to suck his dick
no that's the bit it's the closeted gay
guy that tries to make like everything
that you're watching is gay I mean is it
me or is this gay I I don't think it's
gay it's the [__] Food Network this
guy's making a a tomahawk [__] steak
here yeah it looks just like a dick with
some balls hanging off of it I am I nuts
over
here hey man I I don't know what show
you're watching that is watching a guy
cook a
steak
the guy where everything he sees is gay
is endlessly funny it's endlessly it's
endlessly dude you see momes hug Kelsey
after that game next thing you know he's
gonna [__] grab his ass the [__] was
that all right you go to IKEA
lately the whole thing is I just can't
believe they weren't playing techno
music in there I was like I you see did
you see Harbaugh's dad hug him when they
won the National Championship gay [__]
was that
they were
crying well that Bills fan crying I
would just say that's definitely that's
that was that was more in that direction
than Top Gun all right let's let's
finish this up here all right so let's
do we're gonna
take we're gonna take the
49ers down to minus one meaning they
gotta win the game by one or two and
we're g to take the the Ravens getting
nine and a half at home against the
Chiefs the Chiefs aren't going to beat
the Ravens by 10 dude on in Baltimore
it's not going to [__] happen I'll
put money I'll do a side they they have
too good a coach they have too good a
coach they got too good a coach dude
they got too good a quarterback they got
a no no no no good defense yeah Ravens
getting nine and a half is as good as
you're gonna get and then we'll see what
happens we'll take uh we'll do a two
team tease I don't know Ravens is kind
of a gay bird am I
nuts I mean it's right there it's
just
all right so Rens so the rav the Ravens
you see that logo the Chiefs I mean
there was a guy dressed up like a chief
in the Village People I mean they're
practically serving it up on the platter
that whole organization is gay my nuts
dude we gotta do this when we go to
Vegas we gotta do this uh all right that
is the um that's the show everybody uh
bill has the 49ers and the Chiefs I have
the Ravens and the lions and our special
is the Ravens getting n and a half the
49ers uh giving one point so that's our
two team te's enjoy the te's enjoy the
week and of course make sure you
download the BET MGM we why they call it
a teas I mean that's just so that's
right there I mean kind of te talking
strip teas is that what that I didn't
know where you were
going dude are casinos getting gay tease
I'm a grown man he don't tease me hey
what uh what are they calling this
weekend is it just Championship weekend
this is in uh this keeping it Gully AFC
NFC Championship weekend no they kept
this one traditional this one's Champion
weekend uh all right everybody there you
go that's the show make sure you uh go
to the best sports book out there the
best lines there is it is bmgm our
sponsor you download the app and you use
our code our code is
Burr B RR very easy and the promotion is
awesome you do uh a bet uh up to five a
little as $5 and you will get
$158 in additional bets regardless of
the outcome of your bet so Andrew did I
say that right I want to make sure I
don't mislead people but I think that's
the bet correct there we go there you
go$ five bet responsibly enjoy
Championship weekend uh I am pulling I'm
not gonna lie I'm pulling for the city
of Detroit man I'm pulling for Detroit I
think it would be awesome uh but I also
you know what's funny I'm rooting for
Detroit and I'm rooting for the Ravens
but my money is on the opposite teams uh
but I do love the people of San
Francisco 49ers and uh I love what's it
called pery and those guys it'll be
great like Buffalo Bill fans too except
for the guy that pushed me in the back
when I was taking a leak and that
[__] guy who
cried
uh wide right kind of gay [__] is
that just
everything uh all right uh there you go
guys we'll see you guys uh oh next time
we talk it'll be Super Bowl week we'll
talk to you guys next week I know and
that's the last game of the year Paul
dude it's over this went so quick it it
really was like it didn't happen did it
I mean I feel like when it started I was
in Greece that feels like a zillion
years ago oh dude for me I feel like we
did six weeks of this and it's done but
hey what do I know hey Paul you know
you're in your element you know I just
like doing the show with my friends
[__] gay ass [__] is that you wna all
right uh take care everybody we'll see
you next week couple of bald guys with
closely cropped beards I mean this is
one of the gayest podcasts you could be
is it
me trying too I think we're trying too
hard with our backgrounds Paul like you
have like a black I have gray you know
little home plate thing over there you
know I'm just trying too hard I mean
it's just obviously I love the one just
swimming in dicks over here when you go
Batman and Robin kind of gay say some
gay ass [__] you go is it yeah I thought
I was that was kind of cool that beating
up all these weirdos I thought it was
his sidekicking friend I'm sorry yeah uh
all right guys I'll see you guys uh next
week